COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY- SAY
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE THAT IS BEING CALLED
TO ORDER. I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND READ THE ART OR CORBETT
NINETEEN INSTRUCTIONS- LOOKS
LIKE IT'S BEEN SHORTENED. THANK
GOD- WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE HEARING FIVE
VISITING THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED
PUBLIC COMMENT. I MAY BE READ
INTO THE RECORD ARE REPRINTED.
DUE TO ONGOING COVERT SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS AND INCLUDING
GUIDANCE AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING SEATING FOR THIS
HEARING WILL BE VERY LIMITED
FOR THE PRESS AND FOR THE PROP
PUBLIC. ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO
WATCH THE HEARING FROM HIS
LIFE'S DREAM ON THE ASSEMBLY'S
WEBSITE. THE CAPITAL THE
CAPITAL WILL BE OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING BUT
THE PUBLIC IS STRONGLY
ENCOURAGED TO PARTICIPATE VIA
THE WEB PORTAL. REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION OR PHONE ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING
A HEARING IN THE CAPITOL WILL
NEED TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES WHILE IN THE BUILDING. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO MONITOR
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR
UPDATES. THE PHONE NUMBER FOR
TODAY'S HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S.
877-692-8957 ANY ACCESS CODE
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO LET
ME SAY THAT ONE MORE TIME THE
ACCESS CODE. IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO. ZERO TWO. WHO
WERE WAITING FOR MEMBERS TO GET
A QUORUM WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK HERE. AND THE NEWEST
PERMANENT MEMBER OF ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEXANDER LEE.
IF YOUR. SO I WAIT TO MORE
MINUTES AND THEN I WILL HEAR
MISS TOM LOGGER WHO IS YOUR
FIRST- HC. THREE AND CAMARGO SO
IN THE MEANTIME APPROACH TO.
ONE HOUSEKEEPING AGENDA ITEM.
OFF CALENDAR- POOL BY THE
AUTHOR- I NUMBER FOUR S. B.
EIGHTY ONE SKINNER CENTER
DISMISSED OF IN HALF SO IF YOU
HEAR FOR THAT TODAY- CENTER
SKINNER HAS PULLED. IT FROM THE
AGENDA AND WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM WE ONLY HAVE ONE ITEM.
WHEN I PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR- M. WILL DISMISS THAT
POINT ALSO.
YES I'M GONNA GIVE
MR LACKEY ONE MORE MINUTE AS
USUAL WE WILL ALWAYS WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE. SOMEONE
FROM THE OPPOSITE I'LL OF THE
PARTY HERE WHEN WE HAVE A
DISCUSSION ON ANY. ANY BILL-
JIRO GIVEN ANOTHER MINUTE AS A-
SETOR COM LONGER NOTE BEST A
COURTESY THAT WE'VE ALWAYS
EXTENDED- TWO MEMBERS OF THIS.
AND I HAVE THIS MASK ON TO KEEP
COVERED I KNOW WE HAVE NEW
RULES AS TODAY BUT JUST IN CASE
IF YOU'REIN THE BUILDING YOU
HAVE TO STATE COVERED AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE STILL HAVE I'M
MOST OF US ARE VACCINATED BUT
REACHED OUT OF. AN ABUNDANCE.
OF CAUTION. WERE MAINTAINING
THE MASS WITHIN THE CAPITAL
RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU- SO WE
WILL BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM AND
SO WE WILL START WHICH SPECIAL
ORDER ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT THREE KAMLAGER
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE. SENATOR
YOU MAY BE AGAIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR AND GOOD MORNING. TO YOU
AND MEMBERS AND STAFF ALWAYS
GOOD TO. SEE YOU ALL HERE. I AM
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT THREE
THE CALIFORNIA ABOLITION ACT.
THIS AMENDMENT IS LONG OVERDUE
AND I THINK IT IS INCREDIBLY
FITTING TO BRING IT UP AS WE
APPROACH JUNETEENTH MARKING THE
EMANCIPATION OF BLACK PEOPLE
OUT OF SLAVERY IN THE SOUTHERN
PORTION OF THIS COUNTRY. THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
PROHIBITS SLAVERY AND
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE EXCEPT TO
PUNISH CRIME. ACA THREE SEEKS
TO AMEND THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION TO REMOVE SUCH
CONDITIONAL LANGUAGE ABOLISHING
SLAVERY AND INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE WITHOUT EXCEPTION.
OVER NINETY FOUR THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN STATE PRISON.
AFRICAN AMERICANS ACCOUNT 428%
OF THE PRISON POPULATION AND
LESS THAN 6% OF CALIFORNIA'S
OVERALL POPULATION. ALTHOUGH NO
COURTS EXPLICITLY INCLUDE LABOR
AS A CONDITION OF CRIMINAL
SENTENCING THERE IS AN
EXPECTATION THAT MANY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WILL
PERFORM LABOR OFTENTIMES FOR AS
LITTLE AS EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR.
TODAY TWELVE STATES PROHIBIT
AND SLAVE MEN AND INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE BUT EXCEPTION
PROVISIONS FOR CRIMINAL
PUNISHMENT REMAINS CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THOSE STATES. YOU
KNOW SLAVERY WAS A POLITICAL
AND ECONOMIC ENGINE FOR THE
SOUTH IN THIS COUNTRY. AND ONE
SLAVERY WAS ABOLISHED CONVICT
LEASING ANTI LOITERING AND
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE LAWS
POPPED UP. ALL DESIGNED TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP BLACK MEN AND
WOMEN SHACKLED TO SYSTEMS OF
FREE LABOR. INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE FOR THE PUNISHMENT OF
A CRIME A VESTIGE OF THOSE
TIMES REMAINS AN ECONOMIC
ENGINE FOR THIS COUNTRY AND FOR
CALIFORNIA. THE MINIMUM
ESTIMATED ANNUAL VALUE FOR
INCARCERATED LABOR IN OUR
PRISONS AND JAILS ANNUALLY IS
TWO BILLION DOLLARS. IN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE WE SAVE
UP TO ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR BY USING PRISON
LABOR FOR CALIFORNIA IN THAT IS
JUST ONE LABOR PROGRAM.
DISSOLVING THE REMNANTS OF
SLAVERY AND RACIAL INEQUALITY
IS MORE IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER.
ALTHOUGH IT SHOULD ALWAYS BE
IMPORTANT IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
COLORADO PASSED A BALLOT
MEASURE THAT REMOVE SLAVERY AND
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE AS A
CRIMINAL PUNISHMENT FROM ITS
STATE CONSTITUTION LAST YEAR
VOTERS IN NEBRASKA AND UTAH
VOTED TO REMOVE PRISON SLAVERY
FROM THEIR STATE CONSTITUTIONS.
ALSO IN TWENTY TWENTY U. S.
SENATOR MERKLEY FROM OREGON
INTRODUCED A RESOLUTION TO
REMOVE INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE AS
A PUNISHMENT OF A CRIME FROM
THE US CONSTITUTION. ACA THREE
WILL NOT DO AWAY WITH COMMUNITY
SERVICE ALTERNATIVE SENTENCING
PROGRAMS THESE PROGRAMS STILL
FUNCTION IN STATES LIKE
COLORADO WHERE SIMILAR
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS HAVE
TAKEN EFFECT. WE ARE NOT ASKING
THAT LABOR PROGRAMMING WITHIN
FACILITIES BE ABOLISHED SIMPLY
OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE TO
PERFORM AS ORIGINALLY DESIGNED
AND THEY SHOULD BE PROVIDING
OUR INCARCERATED BROTHERS AND
SISTERS WITH AN APPROPRIATE
WAGE. OUR CONSTITUTION SERVES
AS THE GUIDING PRINCIPLE FOR
ALL OTHER STATE LAWS THERE IS
NO PLACE FOR SLAVERY FORCED
LABOUR OR INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE
ON OUR BOOKS IF YOU TAUGHT IN
NEBRASKA CAN DO WHAT. WE CAN
TO. WITH ME IN SUPPORT HERE IN
PERSON ARE YOU MILLION LAND
FROM THE ANTI VIOLENCE SAFETY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT. AND
RASHID LOCKHART OF THE AYE
HYMNS A COLLECTIVE. AND I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU- THE MILAN- YOU MAY
SPEAK FIRST AND THEN RASHID
LOCKHART. SO THE WORD WE'RE
KINDA RUSTY WE HADN'T AN IN
PERSON IF THE PERSON IN A BODY
YEAR YEAR AND A HALF NOW SO IT
IS IT'S GREAT TO ACTUALLY THINK.
RIGHT RIGHT HELLO ARE SO YOU
YOU FIVE MINUTES IN TOTAL JUST
TO ABUSE YOU CAN SPLIT IT UP TO
AN A HALF MINUTES EACH OR YOU
TO DO FOR BUT YOU MAIL LEAVE.
MISS LOCKARD WITH THE- LOCKER
WITH ONLY ONE. MISS OUT LONGER
ONLY ONCE. I PROMISED TO MAKE
YOUR- QUICK CENTER OKAY SO.
GOOD MORE- I'VE LIKE TO YOU ALL.
FOR TAKING THE TIME HEAR US
THIS MORNING MY NAME IS
MILLIONAIRE. I AM THE CHAIR OF
THE CAL. ABOLITION ACT I AM
ALSO MEMBER OF THE- COMMITTEE
OF A- AND IN WHICH IS ABOUT.
SLAVERY NATIONAL. WE ARE NOW.
COALITION THAT COME IS KIND OF
OVER. STATE THAT ARE ALL
SEEKING REMOVE THIS LANGUAGE
FROM THE RESPECTIVE STATES
INVOLVES. CONSTITUTIONS I AM
ALSO WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
UNITED STATES SENATOR JEFF
MERKLEY. IN INTRODUCING THE
FEDERAL RESOLUTION TO ALSO
AMEND THE THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT
OF THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION. MY ARGUMENT TO
SIR. IS THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THERE'S NO MORAL ARGUMENT.
TO BE LEVERED. THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO ENSLAVE A HUMAN
BEING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WAS ONE VOTE AWAY FROM BEING
MADE A SLAVE STATE. I WILL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE. THIS IS MY
HUSBAND SAMUEL BRO HE IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE PROPOSAL THAT
BECAME A CA THREE. HE IS
CURRENTLY HOUSED INSIDE A
LANCASTER STATE PRISON. IN
SOUTH SOUTH US GETTING AND LOS
ANGELES WHERE HE IS AN H. F.
CUSTODIAN WORKER LAST YEAR WHEN
COLBERT NOW. A ROUGH IT INTO OF
HIS WHISTLE HE WAS TASK WITH
GOING INSIDE OF SALES IN
OFFICES AND CLEANING THEM
WITHOUT PROPER PP YEAR. WHY IS
THIS IMPORTANT. BECAUSE ONE
SAMUEL SAID THAT HE WAS AFRAID
FOR HIS LIFE. BECAUSE NO ONE
KNEW WHAT WE WERE DEALING WITH
THAT HE DID NOT WANT TO GO INTO
THOSE SALES HE WAS TOLD THAT IF
HE DID NOT HE WOULD BE HIT WITH
A RULES VIOLATION A ONE
FIFTEEN. WHICH AND TODAY IS THE
MODERN DAY WHIP THE LATCH ON
THE BACK. BECAUSE IF HE DID NOT
GO TO WORK. HE HAD NO CHOICE.
WHAT THAT DOES IS WHEN HE GOES
UP FOR PAROLE. THEY SEE THAT
ONE FIFTEEN IN HIS FILE. THEY
AUTOMATICALLY DENY HIM. BILLS
THEN I'LL START OFF. FIFTEEN
THEN THEY WALK THEM DOWN TEN
SEVEN FIVE. AND THREE YEARS.
PARDON THAT'S ACTUALLY
SEMELHANTE. SOUL WHAT IS HER IN
THE STATE OF. I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
THIS IS ABOUT WAGES. THIS IS
NOT ABOUT WAGES THIS IS ABOUT
FAIR TREATMENT OF HUMAN BEINGS
AND THE FACT THAT WE HAVE ANY
REMNANTS. OF SLAVERY IN
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTITUTION IN
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
AN COMPREHENSIBLE. AND SO I AM
ASKING TODAY FOR THE SUPPORT OF
A CA THREE. FOUR A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU. MISTER LOCKHART.
YOU'RE NOW OUR SECOND INAUGURAL
IN PERSON TESTIMONY THANK YOU
CAN HEAR ME YES OKAY IT'S ON A
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE I WANT TO
THANK YOU SO MY NAME IS BY
SHEETS LOCKHART. YEAH THIS IS
ALL IN THE ROOM THAT DON'T
TOUCH OUR. I SO MY RUSHES TO
LOCKER I AM A FORM THAT COURSE
PER WHO'S THE AGE OF FIFTEEN
HAS BEEN EVER YEAR OF HIS AND
CAR. I'M FORTY THREE YEAR OLD
FOR THE LAST YEARS OF THE AYE
SIR AS AN FOR THE SAME QUINN
FOR APART WHERE I WAS ALSO
DELAY ON AN CREW. DURING THAT.
I DID. CPR NORMAL FIFTY IN.
JUSTICE QUINN. AND THAT THREE
YEAR. AND I'VE ON CALL TO FOUR
HOURS A DAY. AND I WAS ON PAID
FOR. SEVEN DAYS FOR DAYS WE
EXCUSE ME AND THEY HOURS A DAY.
WHERE I WAS MAKE LAST FORTY
EIGHT DOLLARS A MONTH. LABOR
WAS REQUIRED AND I WANTED TO.
AND IF I REFER TO DO MY JOB ALL
I WAS ON CALL FOR THAT THREE.
TO FOUR HOURS A DAY. I WAS.
THREATENED WITH. BASICALLY I
SELL- BENTO INTO SOME.
CONFINEMENT AND MY PER AS
INCARCERATED BY. DOING THE JOB
OF SAY LIVES AND PER. MY TO
EDUCATE. WAS DENIED I WAS THAT
HE WAS EITHER THE- OR EDUCATION.
AND SO I WASN'T ABLE TO FURTHER
PURSUE MY COLLEGE CAREER THAT I
WAS TRYING TO. ACHIEVE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
PROHIBITS SLAVERY AND
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE EXCEPT TO
PUNISH CRIME. YOUR SUPPORT THIS
BILL WOULD AMEND THE
CONSTITUTION ABOLISHED SLAVERY
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE AND ALL
CONTACT FROM INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
IN SPANISH MISSIONS THE BLACK
SLAVES FORCED TO MINE FOR GOLD
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY OF SLAVERY
ONCE DE. TODAY THE PRACTICE
CONTINUES IN THE FORM OF FORCED
LABOR ISN'T PRESENT WHICH FALLS
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON BLACK
LATINO AND ASIAN POPULATIONS.
AND INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. THIS LAW
IS A DIRECT REFLECTION OF THE
LEGACY AND REMNANTS OF SLAVERY
BETTER WOMAN IN EMBEDDED IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM. THERE IS NO WAY
TO DIVORCE IS LANGUAGE FROM
SLAVERY IT'S HISTORIES AN EXTRA
COUPLE FROM THE FOUNDATIONAL
POLICIES AND PRACTICES OF
SLAVERY. SLAVERY IS WRONG NO
MATTER WHAT. CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTION SILVA OUR VALUES
SLAVERY IS NOT A CALIFORNIA BY.
LET'S DO THIS NOW AND SET AN
EXAMPLE YOU TAUNT ADDRESSES
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURES PASSED
SIMILAR MEASURES WITH A 100%
SUPPORT. LET ME ASSURE FLAVORS
NEVER PART OF CALIFORNIA STORY
AGAIN IF GIVEN THE CHANCE I'M
CONFIDENT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
PEOPLE WOULD DECIDE AGAINST
SLAVERY. LET THEM HAVE THEIR
VOICE IN THIS MATTER. I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU. TO MR SAMUEL
BROWN IN A CAR READY PER. WHO
DRAFTED THE LANGUAGE ACA THREE
FROM. STATE PRISON AND IS
CURRENTLY. THE DIRECTOR OF
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE. TO SEND
A KAMLAGER WHO HAS GAMBLED
ENOUGH TO A THREE DURING THIS
THE MOMENT. TO THE WHIMS THE
FAMILY MEMBERS. THE ADVOCATES A
SISTER WARS WORLD WAR
TIRELESSLY ON SLEDGES FROM THE
BEGINNING THANK YOU TO THE
CHECK IN MEMBERS FROM ROBERT TO
SHARE STORY THANK THANK YOU SIR.
AND NOW WILL HAVE A TEST GOOD.
ME TOO AND A FROM PEOPLE THE
ROOM NAY AN ORGAN. SO IF ANYONE
WOULD COMES INTO MY NAME IN
ORDER. YOU MAY DO NOW. AGAIN I
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. AND
AGAIN. YEAH OKAY WE'RE GONNA.
HE HOOKED JUST SEPARATE CALL
THE ROLL AND A LITTLE PIECE OF
AND YOU CAN TESTIFY. UNDER
SECRETARY CALDERON. JONES
SAWYER HERE. LACKEY MADE. OUR
KING. LI. QUIRK HERE SANTIAGO.
SAN TELL WICKS KWARA IS PRESENT
WE ONE ITEM ON. ARKANSAS
CALENDAR A NUMBER SIC S. FOUR
SIX HUESO- CORRECTIONS AS
PROGRAMS. CALL THE ROLL. SENATE
CALENDAR IS NOW APPROVED
WITNESSES FOR ACA THREE- YOU
MAY NOW BEGIN. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF MY NAME
IS ROY KAUFMANN CURRENTLY CHAIR
OF THE BAYPACKETS SACRAMENTAL
SUPPORT ECA THREE LITTLE UNDER
PERCENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR DUFF THANK. GOOD
MORNING SHARON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KEVIN
MCCARTY I SUPPORT ACA THREE ON
BEHALF OF UC BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS THANK YOU
I'M SORRY TO NAME KEVIN MCCARTY
THROUGH HIS OFFICE NOT YOU. YOU
MAY BEGIN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JESSE BURLISON J. E. S. S. E.
B. U. R. L. E. S. O. IN AND ON
BEHALF OF. TENS OF THOUSANDS OF.
CARS READY PEOPLE AT THE THIRTY
ONE YERS WITH A STRONG SUPPORT
AND ON BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN
THANK THANK YOU SIR. HELLO I
DON'T KNOW MAGYAR ON BEHALF OF
ALL OF US ARE NON IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF A CA THREE.
THANK YOU SIR. RANGIORA BILLING
G. WILL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AC THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD
MORNING AND LEYVA SHANK FOUNDER
IMPACT AND I'M HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A CA THREE THANK YOU.
ALLEGRA TAYLOR FOUNDER OF
VILLAGE ADVOCATES A SACRAMENTO
AND MEMBER OF SACRAMENTO ACT WE
ARE STANDING IN SOLIDARITY WITH
AC EIGHT THREE THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING AMERICA MALTA A POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE YOUNG WOMAN'S
FREEDOM CENTER WE ARE PROBABLY
COSPONSORING A C. THREE. THANK
YOU. APRIL GRAYSON SYSTEM FOR
YOUR FREEDOM COALITION PROUD
SUPPORTER OF AC THREE THANK YOU.
GO THANK YOU FILE I'M A CO
FOUNDER OF THAT AND WE WILL BE
WITH A QUALITY LAW CAN NEVER BE
CLOSER TO BE CORRECT. THAT IS
NOT A VERY WET. THANK YOU SIR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE IN THE ROOM
AND FORTY TWO OH TWO YOU'RE NOW
GO TO. ANYONE A CLOSER TO LINE
SIX EVERYONE TO APPEAR- IT
OPERATOR AT&T OPERATOR CAN YOU
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANYONE
THAT MIGHT. TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF
ACA THREE. ABSOLUTELY DISCUSS A
PIE IN FAVOR OF EIGHTY EIGHT
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME THE
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE THEN PLACE IT
BACK INTO THE QUEUE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
TESTIFY IN. FAVOR ONLY. AND WE
WERE LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY STOCK FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
YOU ARE OPEN. NINE FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS VICTORIA
GOMEZ CO FOUNDER AND YOUTH
ORGANIZER WITH PRIDE INSURANCE
AND A CONSTITUENT IN THE GULF
SANTIAGO DISTRICTS AND I AM A
DESCENDANT OF IMMIGRANTS AND
NATIVE PEOPLE HERE ON TURTLE
ISLAND I AM SHOCKED TO THE CORE
OF. EIGHTY THREE AND ENDING
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO'S. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JAY
VAZQUEZ ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A FEW THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WHY TWENTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING THIS CALL
YOU ARE WE HAVE THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
PROBABLY IN SUPPORT OF THE ACA.
PROJECT HOPE. THANK YOU SIR. BY
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
NINETEEN CAN YOU HEAR. YES I
CAN HEAR YOU CAN HEAR ME YOUR
ACCOUNT PLEASE GO AHEAD NAME AN
ORGANIZATION MORNING. GOOD
MORNING MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MARGARET IN
RECOGNIZABLE. NEXT THANK YOU
I'M FORTY ONE YOUR ALLSTATE.
CANACCORD ON ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER
IN STRONG SUPPORT. RIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARIA
PIA CO FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
LEADER PLAN TRUTH BURKE
GENERATION IMMIGRANT AND ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF MY FAMILY ALL
MY LOVE I THINK OUR THREE DAY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AC THREE
AND- INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE.
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING GLENN
BACKUS FOR ONE FAIR WAGE YELLOW
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
AND DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SIXTY TWO YOUR UP PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING GREGORY PUT
OUT WITH MISTER JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE THIRTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. HI THIS IS- ONE EDWARDS
REPRESENTING STARTING OVER INC
AND WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT
BASICALLY. THANK YOU. PINE
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS MAX CORPUS I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE TALK ABOUT THE
ABOLITIONIST SENT TO STRONGLY
IN FAVOR OF A C. EIGHTY THREE
AND I WOULD LIKE TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT THE ENTIRE COUNTRY IS
WATCHING RIGHT NOW I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO PASSAGE. THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE
THIRTY NINE EUROPE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS TROY
WILLIAMS- COMMUNICATIONS
MANAGER FOR THE LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF PASSING THIS
BILL AND ONE IN WHY IT IS
TAKING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
YEARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SANDRA
JOHNSON AND I'M ALL
REPRESENTING LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACA. THREE
ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME'S CHERYL VORONIN
WITHOUT LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND I
MEAN STRONG SUPPORT THE BCA
TERRY. THANK YOU BYE THANK YOU
ONE THIRTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS SHOWN A CALLING
ON BEHALF OF DIGNITY AND POWER
NOW AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY EIGHT THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS MALIA'S THORLEY
WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
WE'RE AND STRONG SUPPORT AND
EASY THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TIFFANY
QUARRELED I'M WITH THE
COALITION FOR JACKSON ECOBILL
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE
NATIONAL ASSEMBLY OF AMERICAN
SLAVERY DEFINITIVE LOS ANGELES
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS
ALEXANDER RODRIGUEZ I'LL BE
HAPPY TO YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN GRAYSON THE POINT EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS AMIR
MUHAMMAD I'M WITH ALL OF THE
FINANCE SACRAMENTO INSTANTLY
YOU MAKE COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY
EIGHT THREE. THANK YOU. FIFTY
TWO YOUR NEXT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SHEER NUMBERS MY
NAME IS A LITTLE- WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND WE ARE A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY EIGHT
PERFECT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CAMILLE MOORE I'M
A CONSTITUENT ANTHONY CAMARGO
IT'S DISTRICT ALL POLL
SUPPORTER AND FORMER MEMBER OF
THE COALITION PROJECT MEZQUITAL
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATIONAL
ASSEMBLY OF AMERICAN SLAVERY
DEPENDENT AND I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN THIRTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE THIRTY SEVEN BILLION YOU
HARRIS. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN. HI MY NAME IS MIKE
GREAT I'M A RETURNING STUDENT
WHO DID SIX YEARS. CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISON AND WE RESPECT.
THE COLLEGE GRADUATE. THE
BOSTON BONTA ELECTIVE WILL
GROUP AND A MEMBER OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND
PROBLEMS FOR ACA THIRTY ENDING
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. LINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KELLY WALTERS I AM A STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN OUT
OF OAKLAND CALIFORNIA YEAH I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT HE'S
GREAT. LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING DAILY TRIPS
HE WOULD BE A NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER SHOWING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A FEE. THANK
YOU. LINE TWENTY SEVEN EUROPE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR DYLAN
RODRIGUEZ PROFESSOR UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE AND
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
STUDIES ASSOCIATION I'M CALLING
OFF MY UNEQUIVOCAL SUPPORT
BRACE EIGHT THREE AND DEMAND
THAT CALIFORNIA'S STOP INDOORS
AND SLAVERY. THANK YOU. WE WILL
ALIGN FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT
THREE THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. OUR SKEWS
ME I TAKE THAT BACK LINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME GIRL WHO- ELLER THE ALL
THE COMMENTS SACRAMENTO.
ARCHERY SUPPORT XP EIGHT THREE
THANK YOU. OKAY ONE MORE A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR-
EIGHT AC EIGHT THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ALMA ROBINSON I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS FOR THE ARTS
I'M ALSO AFFILIATED WITH THE
ABOLISHED SLAVERY NATIONAL
NETWORK AND I'M ON THE POLICY
COMMITTEE OF THE FREE AT LAST
COALITION. IN ADDITION I AM
INVOLVED WITH SOCIAL JUSTICE
COMMITTEE AS OF GRACE CATHEDRAL
ARTIST COUPLE CHURCHES TAKEN A
STAND ON TO AMEND THE
THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT A CA
THREE AS A DOWN PAYMENT
BECAUSE- THEY ARE IMPORTANT
ELEVEN. ON SERVITUDE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY BLOOD REPRESENTING ALL OF
THE AND NINE. AND REUNITE
FAMILIES COSTA THE WORST PART
OF THE HE COULD THANK YOU SIR.
LINE TWENTY TWO YOUR UP. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CRITICIZED  CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHT THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY WHITE STAR SKEWS ME
SEVENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES THE
NAME IMPLEMENTATION OKAY HI MY
NAME. YES ANSLEY EVANS WITH
YOUNG YOUNGER PREGNANT SISTER
SUPPORTER FREEDOM COALITION ON
THE OUTSIDE OF THE TO WORKERS
IN COLLEGES ALL THE COURTS RELY
GOOD FAITH CALIFORNIA VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINES
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I
THOUGHT YOUR OPEN SIR- GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WITH THE
ENGINEER- REPRESENTATIVE-
CANDIDATE FOR THE THIRD DAY
DISTRICT IN CONGRESS NUMBER OF
FUN RIDE MOVED AWAY NO THERE-
THE LOVE WITH ALL THE AND
PROJECT. ON THE LAKE AND I'M
CALLING IN- A. EIGHT THANK YOU.
LINES SIX CALL. I'M IN THE
PROCESS HELLO YEAH IT I'M POINT.
THANKS FOR. RIGHT SEVENTY FIVE
GO AHEAD. HI NAME IS ANTONIO
QUORUM ON THE DOOR OF A IN IN A
MEMBER OF RIVERSIDE ALL OF US
NOW I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY EIGHT DURING.
THANK YOU. SIXTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS IN ORDER TO
COME WITH ALL OF US ARE NOT
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER AS A PERSON
WHO WAS EXPOSED TO SLAVE LABOR
TO INCARCERATION CONTINUES TO
BE ESCALATED I WILL TO
SUPPORTING STATE THREE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR. LINE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR UP. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS GERRY SILVA I AM OF THE
DIRECTOR ™FAIR
COORDINATOR FOR FAMILIES UNITED
AND THE L. LOCK I 1100% UNITE
WITH EVERY SPEAKERS THIS
MORNING TO CONGRATULATE SENATOR
COM LOCKER AND LET'S GO WITH
THIS. THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT ACA
THROUGH. THANK YOU MA'AM THANK.
ON LINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS TRIBAL RAN WITH
THE BALL COPY ABOLITIONIST
CENTER AND A MEMBER OF THE ANC
THE IN I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE ASA THREE BILL.
THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY EUROPE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT IT'S
REALLY HONORABLE SHAY FRANCO
CLAUSEN PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
ABOLITION ACT AND LEGISLATIVE
MANAGER AND I AM THRILLED I
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY THREE. THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT MY NAME IS WILLIAM
I AM. LEGAL SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVES AND
COMMUNICATIONS DEPARTMENT
FELLOW I DO THIRTY ONE YEARS I
PRISON AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR. EIGHTY EIGHT
THREE. THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. YES THANK
YOU- MY NAME ONLY BECAUSE OTHER
POLICY DIRECTOR AND I'M COMMON
LAW WE'RE STRONG SUPPORT OF A
FEW THREE. I THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING IT. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU. OTHER ANY WITNESSES- THAT
IS OPPOSITION OF ACA THREE
THERE IN OPPOSITION OF
INVOLUNTARY SEWER SERVITUDE IN
THE AUDIENCE. BECAUSE I HAVE NO
SPEAKERS SCHEDULED TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF INDIAN
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE ON THE
LINE. A OPERATE EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR YOU MAY OPEN UP A LOT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- TO SHOW
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY EIGHT
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND AGAIN
TO SHOW OPPOSITION TO BILL
EIGHTY EIGHT THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE PARTICIPANT KILLING UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FOR ANYBODY
ELSE TO SH. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. I APOLOGIZE
THERE STILL WITH THE OPERATOR
THEY'LL- ASSEMBLY QUESTION WE
WILL LINE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS ANGELA
NIRVANA FOR THE COALITION FOR A
JOKES AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A
CA THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU M.
AT MISTER CHAIR THERE'S NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS OKAY THIS
TIME. THANK YOU EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR WILL NOT BRING IT TO
THE COMMITTEE MISTER. OR DO YOU
WANT TO ASK FOR THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY. MIGHT APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN TO WHICH- WE STILL I
WILL I'LL I'LL GOAHEAD AND ASK
FOR ANY REMOTE TESTIMONY. FOR
OR AGAINST. ACA THREE. THERE'S
NO ONE IN THE ROOM. SO MISTER
CLARK IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION OR
COMMENT YOU MAY NOW YEAH SORRY
THE COMMENT AND YOU CAN RESPOND
IN YOUR CLOSE UP MY KIDS SO
FIRST OF ALL LET ME MOVE THE
BELL. I'M SURE YOU'LL GET A
VERY GOOD VOTE OUT OF. GET OUT
OF COMMITTEE GO ON THE BALLOT
AND- I WOULD HOPE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THEN APPROVE IT. BUT
MY PROBLEM IS THAT IT MAY NOT.
JUST CHANGING THIS DEPENDS UPON
THE COURT'S INTERPRETATION. OF
WHAT IT MEANS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE AND
PRISONS. IT COULD BE THAT
NOTHING CHANGES OR COULD BE
EVERYTHING CHANGES IT ALL
DEPENDS UPON THE COURTS. WHAT
WE REALLY NEED TO DO AND THIS
IS TRUE WHETHER THIS AMENDMENT
PASSES OR NOT IS AS A
LEGISLATURE AND I WOULD HOPE
YOU WOULD LEAD THIS EFFORT. TO
COME UP WITH NEW RULES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF. THE BILL
ATTENTION CORRECTIONS- SHOULD
WE BE PAYING MINIMUM WAGE OR
SOME FRACTION THEREOF. THAT
WOULD PROBABLY COST ABOUT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR WHICH
THEN WOULD COME OUT OF OTHER
PROGRAMS. BUT MAYBE THAT'S AN
INVESTMENT WE WANT TO MAKE.
PARTICULARLY IF WE COULD KEEP
THAT MONEY IN TRUST UNTIL A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF AND TRUST
INTO PEOPLE GOT OUT. WE COULD
HAVE A MUCH LOWER RECIDIVISM
RATE SO I CAN SEE THE REAL
ADVANTAGES OF THAT. BUT
REGARDLESS OF WHAT IT IS WE
DECIDE WE SHOULD DECIDE AND
THAT'S TRUE WHETHER THIS PASSES
OR NOT. SO WHEN YOU'RE CLOSE-
I'M HOPING THAT YOU WILL PLEDGE
TO BRING FORWARD A BILL. TO
DISCUSS WHAT THE PARAMETERS
SHOULD BE SO THAT WE KNOW THAT
WE WILL GET REAL CHANGE THANK
YOU. WE WANT TO DO IT IN YOUR
CLOTHES. YES HELLO MISS WICKS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WHEN I THINK OF THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING ABOUT THIS BILL AND
YOUR LEADERSHIP NOT NOT ONLY ON
THIS ISSUE BUT ACROSS THE BOARD
INCOME ADDRESSES REFORM ISSUES.
AND WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE. C. IN UPPER MISSION MR
LEE I THANK THE SENATOR FOR
BRING THIS IMPORTANCE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT IT'S
IT WAS REAL STAND ON
CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY THAT STILL
EXISTS HERE I THINK OBVIOUSLY
IT IS ALL ONLY JUST COMMENT BUT
OF THE QUALIFIED EXEMPTION OF
SLAVERY THAT STILL PERSISTS
AFTER THE CIVIL WAR IN THE CASE
EXCEPT FOR PUNISHMENT IS
OBVIOUSLY A GLARING ERROR IN
THAT AND OBVIOUSLY ONE HAS
FUELED THE MASS INCARCERATION
EXIST IN THIS COUNTRY AND I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT WE'RE TAKING
THE AFFIRMATIVE STEP TOWARDS
ERASING. THE EVOLUTION OF
SLAVERY EXISTENCE COUNTRY WE
KNOW THIS EXISTS FOR WAGES-
EXPLOITATION THROUGH MAKING A
PRISON INMATES CONDUCT ACTUAL
VITAL SERVICES IN PRODUCTION
THAT'S LIKE THIS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY SO HOPEFULLY AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ARCHIVE OF THE
SPACE ALLUDED TO HOPEFULLY WILL
BE TAKING THE ON THAT WOULD
LOVE TO JOIN YOU IN THAT EFFORT
TO MAKE SURE THAT REAL HUMAN
TAKING A REAL HUMAN LABOR IS
ACTUALLY VALUE THIS EVEN THE
CONTACTS OF PRISONS THEY'RE
STILL HUMAN BEINGS AND THEY
SHOULD BE TREATED AS SUCH- WE
DIDN'T SENTENCE THEM SET YOU
FREE LABOR. AND ANY SIX ANY
OTHER CONTACTS THAT IS SLAVERY
OF COURSE- SO REALLY HOPEFULLY
THAT WE WILL BE WORK ON THE.
CENTER AND I'M HAPPY SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER COM. YOU MAY CLOSE MISS
CALLER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
FIRST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
AGENDA ISING THIS ITEM- SO THAT
WE COULD HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. I WANT TO-
ADDRESS THE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS RAISED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK IN FACT
THERE. IS CASE LAW ON THE BOOKS
DATING BACK TO EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
THREE. ON THE-
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF SLAVERY IN
FACT IN NINETEEN ELEVEN- BAILEY
V. ALABAMA THEY ACTUALLY
QUESTIONED IT WITH REGARDS TO
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE. THIS IS
ABOUT TAKING THIS ISSUE OUT OF
THIS BODY INTO THE VOTERS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BY PUTTING IT
ON A BALLOT- IT COULD BE
CHALLENGED IN THE COURTS IT
COULD GO TO THE STATE SUPREME
COURT IT COULD GO TO THE NINTH
CIRCUIT- I BELIEVE THEY'RE
STANDING BECAUSE THERE ARE
OTHER STATES WHO HAVE ALSO
PASSED THIS- AND HAVE AND ARE
BEGINNING THE CONVERSATIONS.
AROUND DIGNIFIED AND
APPROPRIATE WAGES AND PAY.
ULTIMATELY- THERE ARE TWO
ISSUES WHAT. OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION SAYS AND THEN WHAT
ARE PENAL CODE SECTION SAYS AND
OTHER LAWS ON THE BOOKS THAT WE
HAVE AS WELL AS OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AROUND WHAT IS AN
APPROPRIATE WAGE AND I HOPE-
THAT AID THIS PASSES AND THAT
BE WE CAN CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT IS AN
APPROPRIATE WAGE FOR SOMEONE
WHO IS INCARCERATED- AND THAT.
PEOPLE WILL GET UNCOMFORTABLE.
BECAUSE IT WILL ULTIMATELY
FORCE FOLKS TO DECIDE. THE
VALUE OF THE BODY WHILE THEY
ARE INCARCERATED THE VALUE OF A
PERSON WHILE THEY ARE
INCARCERATED. AND I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THAT WILL LEAD US BUT IT
SURELY SHOULD LEAD US TO
SOMEPLACE OTHER THAN EIGHT
CENTS AN HOUR. YOU KNOW THE
PENAL CODE SAYS THAT CDCR SHALL
REQUIRE OF EVERY ABLE BODIED
PRISONER IMPRISONED IN ANY
STATE PRISON AS MANY HOURS. OF
FAITHFUL LABOR IN EACH DAY AND
EVERY DAY. DURING HIS OR HER
TERM OF IMPRISONMENT AS SHALL
BE PRESCRIBED BY THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS OF THE DIRECTOR F
CORRECTIONS. WHEN I READ THAT.
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF. THIS IS
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT I WOULD
HEAR. IN A STORY ABOUT A SLAVE
OWNER AND A PLANTATION. AND HOW
DO WE RE ENGINEER. WHAT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE LOOKS LIKE
WHAT OUR CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM
SHOULD LOOK LIKE AND HOW WE
TREAT PEOPLE. THESE ARE REAL
VESTIGES OF SLAVERY THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH THAT YOU ALL DEAL
WITH EVERY SINGLE TIME THE BILL
COMES BEFORE YOU IN MANY
INSTANCES MISTER LOCKHART WHILE
HE DIDN'T SAY. HAD TO ACTUALLY
GET PERMISSION. FROM HIS PAROLE
OFFICER. TO COME HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY. IF THAT ISN'T HAVING A
SILENT INVISIBLE SHACKLE ON YOU.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS. SOI AM
HOPING THAT YOU WILL VOTE ON
THIS BILL THAT IT WILL ALLOW WE
WILL BE ALLOWED TO BRING IT TO
THE FLOORS AND ULTIMATELY THAT
WE WILL BE ALLOWED TO BRING
THIS TO THE VOTERS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO YOU KNOW WORDS
MATTER WORDS. MATTER BECAUSE
THEY PRESCRIBE OUR VALUES AND I
HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT IN. THIS
YEAR. OF THIS CENTURY WE ARE
WORKING. TO RE THINK. SOME OF
THE REMNANTS OF TIMES THAT WERE
NOT GOOD TO CERTAIN PEOPLE. AND
TO FIX THOSE SO IN THE WORDS OF
ONE OF THE CALLERS. MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE LET'S DO
THIS LET'S PASS ACA THREE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. IN OUR AND I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD ESPECIALLY SO
CLOSE TO COUNTY. AND WHEN YOU
REALLY THINK OF JUNETEENTH LIKE
A LOT OF CELEBRATIONS FOR A LOT
OF DAYS THAT WE HONOR WHAT IS
HAPPENED IN THE PAST. IF YOU
REALLY THINK ABOUT JUNETEENTH
IT'S ABOUT DELAYING JUSTICE I'M
IN TEXAS BOB SLAYTON TAXES
WEREN'T NOTIFIED. WHEN SLAVERY
ENDED AND IT WAS DELIBERATE. IT
WAS DELIBERATE BECAUSE IT WAS
ECONOMICALLY NOT IN TEXAS'S
ADVANTAGE TO LET PEOPLE FREE
LABOR. OUT OF TEXAS SLAVERY WAS
BEGUN BECAUSE OF FREE LABOR.
INDENTURED SERVITUDE BACK IN
ENGLAND WAS ALL ABOUT COMPANIES
BEING ABLE TO GET THE CHEAPEST
LABOR EVEN CHILD LABOR. TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP THE ECONOMY GOING.
REASON WE WERE THREE FIFTHS A
PERSON BECAUSE YOU CAN'T FORCE
BEEN INDIVIDUAL TO WORK FOR
LESS. UNLESS YOU DOWNGRADE THEM
IN THAT MANNER AND THAT'S WHY
WE WERE ABLE TO GET AWAY WITH
SLAVERY WHICH BUILT THIS
COUNTRY. BUILT THIS ON THE
BACKS OF SLAVES THEY GO ALL THE
WAY BACK FORTY YEARS AGO. AND
SO IT'S AN ECONOMIC AND. FOR
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS READ. JUST
THINK OF IT- IF WE HAD PAID
THIS MAN WHAT HE WAS WORTH. I
NOTICED A SKETCH ABOUT HOW UCH
MONEY THAT IS BUT WE HAVE PAID
THIS MAN WHO IS WORTH A
THOUSAND DOLLARS A WEEK THAT
YOU WOULD PAY A FIREFIGHTER. HE
WILL WALK OUT OF PRISON ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO START HIS LIFE ALL OVER
AGAIN. YEAH HE ACTUALLY EARNED
BY PUTTING HIS LIFE ON THE LINE.
THAT'S REPARATIONS I'M ON
REPARATIONS ISSUE BE PART OF IT
WE SHOULD LOOK AT ALL THE LAWS
THAT HAVE KEPT AFRICAN
AMERICANS LATINOS AND OTHERS
BEHIND. SO THAT WE EVEN THE
PLAYING FIELD SO THEY CAN BE
EQUAL. TO EVERYONE ELSE AND-
YOU'RE ASKING WHERE DO WE GO
NEXT AS PART OF PREPARATIONS.
THIS SHOULD BE PART OF IT IS
MISTER KIRK WAS SAYING WHERE DO
WE GO NEXT. THIS WHOLE CONCEPT
OF PAYING PEOPLE OF REMOVING
ALL THE VESTIGES OF SLAVERY AND
OTHER THINGS THAT KEPT PEOPLE
DOWN. MAYBE THAT'S WHERE WE
START WITH THE LOSS AND EVEN
THE NAMING OF THINGS I'M ALSO
ON A ON A COMMITTEE THAT LOOKS
AT THE NAMING. UP THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE RACIALLY
INSENSITIVE INSENSITIVE THAT
HAVE KEPT PEOPLE BACK BECAUSE-
THE RACIST NAMES AND ID.
DOWNGRADE THE WHOLE SOCIETY OF
PEOPLE WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT THAT
TOO. BECAUSE THAT'S ALSO PART
OF REPARATIONS. AND SO THE
REASON THAT THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT. NOT ONLY TO BEGIN
THE CONVERSATION. BUT IT HELPS
ME TO VALIDATE WHY WE NEED TO
HAVE THIS AS PART OF
REPARATIONS AND SO I THANK YOU
BECAUSE YOU NOT ONLY MAKE MY
JOB EASIER AS A MEMBER OF THE
REPARATIONS COMMITTEE. BUT I
THINK- WE YOU WOULD HAVE SET
HE STAGE FOR THE DIALOGUE THAT
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD SO THE
CHAIRS RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE.
CALL THE ROLL. ACA THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER BY JOHN SO YOU'RE A
LACKEY. LACKEY AT A BARRICADE
HAND BARRICADE HANNAH HI LETE
LETE I WORK OUR WORK AYE SAN.
SAN DIEGO I SEE R. TWO WICKS
WICKS I. THAT MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND NOW
WE'RE RETURN TO REGULAR ORDER
BUSINESS. I SEE MISTER REQUIRES
HERE- ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
SEVENTY ONE MCGUIRE INFRACTIONS
COMMUNITY SERVICE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. SECOND. ALL RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR INTO
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH I
WILL BE VERY BRIEF LONG STORY
SHORT AS YOU ALL KNOW AND
APPRECIATE THE MOTION SB
SEVENTY ONE WILL PROVIDE JUDGES
WITH AN ADDITIONAL TURNER DID
TO OFFER INDIVIDUALS TO MEET
THE COMMUNITY SERVICE OUR
REQUIREMENT WE FACE IN OUR
FINES IN FEES OF COURSE LIFT UP
THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE AT THE
SAME TIME I MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK ON THIS AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING OBVIOUSLY THE
COMMITTEE NAMES TODAY THEY'RE
BEING PROPOSED. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR YOUR TIME EFFORT ENERGY ON
THE BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
MCGUIRE. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES. SO ON. YES WE DO- WE
DO HAVE WITNESSES WHO WERE ON
THE LINE I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR. VERY
GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE. THE
NECESSARY. WHO IS WITH US IN
THE WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE.
THANK YOU. MISTER AND YOU MAY
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
SHE'S ON THE MORNING CARE
MEMBER. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES.
HI MY NAME IS VANESSA THURMOND
AND A WOMAN POLICY INSTITUTE
FELLOW SPEAKING AT THE BORDER
SB SEVENTY ONE ON BEALF OF THE
ALL NEW POLICIES YOU.
CALIFORNIA TRAFFIC FINES AND
FEES ARE SOME OF THE HIGHEST IN
THE COUNTRY CREATING UNBEARABLE
THAT CURRENTLY JUDGES CAN FIND
COMMUNITY SERVICE AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO PAYMENT BUT MORE
MUST BE DONE ACCORDING TO A
TWENTY NINETEEN UCLA REPORT LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS FACED
WIDESPREAD BARRIERS GOING TO
COMPLETING MANDATORY COMMUNITY
SERVICE INCLUDING STATE HOURS
LANGUAGE ACCESS ATTENDING
SCHOOL OR FAMILY OBLIGATIONS
MAINTAINING EMPLOYMENT AND LACK
OF TRANSPORTATION. THE RANGE OF
HOURS IMPOSED BY COMMUNITY
SERVICE ORDERS ARE OFTEN
BETWEEN FIFTY ONE AND A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE THAT'S ABOUT ONE
WEEK AND A HALF. TO FOUR WEEKS
AGO KIND WORK. AND TO
COMPLETELY SERVICE HOURS. LEAD
TO CONSEQUENCES INCLUDE A REST
INCARCERATE DEATH AND ARE KIND
OF PEOPLE COURT ORDERED
COMMUNITY SO WHAT THE STATUS TO
AVOID. SENATE BILL SEVENTY ONE
WOULD EXPAND SERVICE THE- AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE YOURSELF
BACK IN ADULT LEARNING CLASSES
CAN MAKE COLLEGE COURSES AND
APPRENTICESHIPS. OFFERING
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND JOB
TRAINING COURSES IT'S AN
EFFECTIVE ALTERNATIVE FOR LOW
INCOME COUNTY MEMBERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE ACCEPTABLE ON WEEKEND
WEEKENDS AND EVENINGS. OPTION
WOULD INTERFERE IN LAST AND NOT
ALL NOT AT ALL WITH EMPLOYMENT
DUTIES I WOULD ALLOW COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO LEARN A NEW SKILL
AND YOU FEEL THAT WOULD
INCREASE EMPLOYMENT.
OPPORTUNITY AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY. HOW NEEDS DO BETTER
AFTER FLOOD. IN THE ALTERNATIVE
TO PAIN FINES AND SB SEVENTY
ONE WILL DO SO WHILE ALSO
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO
PARTICIPATE IN ACTIVITIES THAT
WILL ENHANCE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE. I WILL HAVE LONG LASTING
BENEFITS TO WORKING FAMILIES
IT'S JUST POSTURING LIFELONG
LEARNING AND PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
PATHWAYS INTO HIGHER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A NEW JOB OR
INCLUDE JOB WHICH ULTIMATELY
BENEFIT OUR COMMUNITY. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE SB SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU
CARE. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
WITHIN THE CHAMBER ON SB SEVEN
ONE. THAT WOULD LIKE TO ME MAKE
A COMMENT. ANYONE ON THE VIDEO
SCREEN SEEN NONE ANYONE ONLINE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR ARE THERE
ANY. I SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZEROS
SHOW SUPPORT FOR A SB SEVENTY
ONE THANK YOU. OUR FIRST
PURCHASE WILL BE LINE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARCO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHEN THE WATER WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OUR LINE TWENTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. DANIEL GOOD CARE OF THEM
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. I NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IMMEDIATELY
WHAT NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTERS ON SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE FINAL REMINDER OUT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT AT THIS TIME FOR
SB SEVENTY ONE AND WE WERE LINE
SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
SHARING TWENTY MEMBERS ALONG
WITH YOUR OWN PATH EIGHT
BILLION COPY ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ALMOST PROJECT WE HAVE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME. NO OTHER NO OTHER
FOR SUPPORT WE WANT BARBECUING
OUT BUT I GUESS WE HAVE ONE
LEAST REGULAR ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THERE WITH AN OPERATOR. THE US
MOMENTARILY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS BEYOND
THE GENTRAN WOULD BE A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY- FOR SELF
SUFFICIENCY ON TIME TO AND I'M
SHOWING MY SUPPORT TODAY. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY ONE IN OPPOSITION I
SEE NO SPEAKERS- WITNESSES
RIGHT ANYONE A ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVENTY ONE.
ANYONE IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCE
ROOM. AND IS IT ANYONE ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION. AT&T
OPERATOR SB SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU MISTER GRISHAM OPPOSITION
FOR A BILL SB SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. I HAD TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY CHAU OPPOSITION FOR
SB SEVENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE ARE
GETTING NO PARTICIPATION AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS CONCERNS.
CONGRATULATIONS HAVE A QUICK
COMMENT. I NOTICED THE
UNDERVOTE HISTORY THAT THERE'S
INDICATION TODAY THAT YOU DID
NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL I WAS
JUST CURIOUS AS TO WHY THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN. THAT I DIDN'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL WELL IT YOU
DIDN'T VOTE AGAINST IT SAYS NO
VOTE RECORDED. YOU KNOW I'M NOT
SURE BECAUSE I CARRIED THE BILL
LAST YEAR- IN- WE HAD TO PARK
THE BILL BECAUSE OF CODED- BUT-
I'M NOT SURE WE THINK IT WAS
OUR CONSENT. YOU MAY NOT OF. I
MAY BE IN IN A MEETING I'M I'M
NOT SURE ENOUGH YEAH OKAY YEAH
YOU'RE YOU'RE- A REASONS CAN
YOU BECAUSE ON MY BUILD PEACE
ACT I DIDN'T VOTE AND I WAS AT
FORTY. OF COURSE. ISN'T LEGAL
SOMEBODY ASKED ME WHEN YOU
GOING TO VOTE FOR YOUR BILL
NICE THERE IS A- VERY BIG AND I
WAS LIKE LOOK AT ME THAT'S ALL.
YEAH IT'S DEFINITELY AN
INTERESTING POINT. I DIDN'T SEE
NO OTHER FURTHER COMMENTS YOU
MAY CLOSE MISTER MCGUIRE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN STRUCTURE.
AND THANK YOU MISTER MCGUIRE
BECAUSE I'VE JUST THE- THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG ABOUT. THE REASON
I WE JUST CLARIFICATION BECAUSE-
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GENUINE
HEART IS. AND I JUST IN MY NAME
MISUNDERSTANDING OF WHAT YOUR
INTENT IS- AGAIN WE WORK
TOGETHER FOR QUITE A FEW THINGS
AND IS THAT REALLY WISHES TO
CLARIFY JUST IN CASE. SOMEONE
WERE TO TAKE IT TO AN A LEVEL
THAT YOU WOULD NEVER. NEVER
NEVER INTENDING IT TO SO THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE OF THE
AMENDMENT OF COURSE SIR THANK
YOU FOR THE LEGION WORK WITH
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH. MATTER
CULTURAL. SB ONE BY SENATOR THE
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER
AND LACKEY LACKEY I BARRICADE
HAN LI LI HI CORK CORK I
SANTIAGO. C. R. CHAU WICKS
WICKS I. THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS. I
DO NUMBER THREE SB SEVENTY
THREE WIENER PROBATION
ELIGIBILITY CRIMES RELATING TO.
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. GOOD.
THE IBM TIMES TAKEN ABACK I
HEARD NOISE IN THE HALL IT'S
BEEN SO LONG SINCE I'VE HEARD
AND OUR PEOPLE TALKING IN THE
HALL I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
ABOUT WE'RE BACK TO LIFE. THE
STUFF UP ANY- AND FOR- THANK
YOU- MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
RECORD I DID VOTE FOR THIS BILL
IN THE SENATE. I GUESS. THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT- SO- OUR
COLLEAGUES- THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THIS BILL TODAY. SENATE
BILL SEVENTY THREE- WHICH YOU
HAVE SEEN- BEFORE- I CARRY THIS
BILL LAST YEAR THAT A MOVE
BECAUSE ECHO OF IT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARCADIO HAS CARRIED IN
THE PAST CENTER SKINNER HAS
CARRIED AND WE'RE HOPING TO
FINALLY. GET IT DONE THIS YEAR-
EXCUSE ME THREE WILL REPEAL
MANDATORY MINIMUM JAIL
SENTENCES FOR PEOPLE CONVICTED
OF CERTAIN. NONVIOLENT DRUG
OFFENSES- BY PROVIDING JUDGES
WITH THE DISCRETION- TWO FIVE
CENTS PERSON TO PROBATION-
BASED ON THE FACTS OF THE CASE-
IT'S I THINK SURPRISING TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAN IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA- WE STILL
HAVE A SITUATION. WHERE PEOPLE
ARE CONVICTED OF NONVIOLENT
DRUG OFFENSES- AND- A JUDGE IS
MANDATED TO SEND THE PERSON. TO
JAIL OR PRISON AND HAS NO
DISCRETION WHATSOEVER- TO PUT
THE PERSON ON PROBATION NO
MATTER WHAT THE FACTS OF THE
CASE ARE- IT FLIES IN THE FACE
OF. OUR EFFORTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO AND THE WAR ON
DRUGS- TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH. AND TO GIVE JUDGES
THE FLEXIBILITY TO- SENDS
PEOPLE BASED ON THE FACTS. OF
THE CASE. AS ALL THIS BILL DOES
JUDGES. A JUDGE CAN STILL SENDS
A PERSON. TO JAIL IF THE JUDGE
THINKS IT'S APPROPRIATE. THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE WITH THE
MAXIMUM. SENTENCES THE JUDGE
WILL RETAIN ALL THE TOOLS TO
ISSUE AN APPROPRIATE SENTENCE.
BUT THE JUDGE WILL HAVE. THE
DISCRETION TO PLACE A PERSON ON
PROBATION IF THE JUDGE.
DETERMINES IS APPROPRIATE.
BASED ON THE FACTS. OF THE
CASE- THE COLLEAGUES AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR IN THE CASE OF
THE THIS BILL TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I WITH ME TODAY-
TESTIFIED BY PHONE. OR JUDGE
HARLING GROSSMAN WHO IS A
RETIRED SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE
FROM COST. CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
AND NEXT TO OATEN WHO ISN'T.
ATTORNEY WITH THE LAW ANGELES
PUBLIC WITH OFFICE THANK YOU.
AT&T OPERATOR. COMING OUT HERE
FROM THE WITNESSES. MISTER
STEWART OPEN NEXT DOOR TO OPEN
AND A JUSTICE. FOR ALL OKAY IT
NEEDS TO KNOW NOW ITH HAPPY
THAT HUMANA WELL I WOULD DEFER
TO JUDGE CRESSMAN BUT I CAN- I
CAN CERTAINLY GO FIRST MAKE
CERTAIN SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDER
DISSERTATION I AM THE POWER
TURNING THE LOS ANGELES PUBLIC
DEFENDER. AND SEVENTY THREE
DRESSES INEQUITY IN THE LAW
REQUIRING MINIMUM. FOR
NONVIOLENT DRUG OFFENDERS UNDER
CURRENT LAW A PERSON EACH WHITE
COMMITTEE PULP QUITE KIELDER
TWICE THE DEATH IS AN ILLEGAL
WEAPON IS NOT SUBJECT TO A
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCE. IT
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
JUDGES TO TREAT CASES
INDIVIDUALLY HANDING DOWN DEATH
SENTENCES THAT MAKE THE MOST
SENSE THAT INDIVIDUAL THE
PUBLIC BASED ON THE SPECIFIC
FACTS OF THE CASE. THAT
INDIVIDUAL HISTORY- AND PUBLIC
SAFETY CONCERNS UNFORTUNATELY
UNTIL NOW THAT YOU HAVE NOT
BEEN GRANTED THE SAME
DISCRETION FOR MANY NON VIOLENT
DRUG OFFENSES MEANING THAT
IRONICALLY COURTED AND REQUIRED
TO ATTEND CALIFORNIA CONNECT OF
NONVIOLENT DRUG OFFENSE THE
JAIL OR PRISON. EVEN WHEN DOING
SO IS NOT IN THE INTERESTS THE
PUBLIC AN INDIVIDUAL. SB THIRTY
THREE PRESS WITH THE CRAP IN
THE BY REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT
THAT JUDGES TEND CALIFORNIA TO
JAIL OR PRISON FOR NONVIOLENT
DRUG OFFENSES WELL STILL GIVING
THEM THAT CREDIT DISCRETION TO
DO SO IN AN APPROPRIATE CASE.
BECAUSE THE BILL SIMPLY BRING
DRUG SENTENCING INTO LINE WITH
THE SENTENCING OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO COURTS AND OTHER
NON DRUG CASES. WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JUDGE GROSSMAN. MORNING AND I
APOLOGIZE I WAS WAITING FOR THE
EIGHTEENTH CAN OPERATE WITHIN.
TELL ME TO A NEW. I AM HARLEM
GROSSMAN ON THE RETIRED JUDGE
FROM CONTRA COSTA COUNTY I
RETIRED NINE YEARS AGO AFTER
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF JUDICIAL
SERVICE. I WAS A PROSECUTOR FOR
NINE YEARS BEFORE BECOMING A
JUDGE. SINCE RETIRING I'VE BEEN
ACTIVE IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
POLICY ADVOCATES THE- I'M
GIVING TESTIMONY THIS MORNING
TO ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SEVENTY THREE.
WHICH WOULD REPEAL THE
PROBATION INELIGIBILITY AND
PARTICLES PENSION OF SENTENCES
PROVISIONS FOR CERTAIN
ENUMERATED NONVIOLENT DRUG
OFFENSES. THEIR BY STAFF
RESTORING JUDICIAL DISCRETION
TO IMPOSE APPROPRIATE SENTENCES
TAILORED TO THE INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES OF EACH DEPENDENT
THAT COME BEFORE THE COURT.
RESTRICTIONS ON JUDICIAL
DISCRETION IN SENTENCING DID
NOT SERVE AS A DETERRENT TO
CRIME. RATHER THEY ONLY SERVE
TO LIMIT THE DISCRETION OF THE
ANTI THE HANDS OF JUDGES
INVOLVED IN THE EDUCATION THIS
POSITION AND RESOLUTION OF
THESE CASES. IT MAKES LITTLE
SENSE TO LIMIT JUDICIAL
DISCRETION AND THAT'S SOMETHING
OF THESE MATTERS WHEN JUDGES
RETAIN AND EXERCISE THEIR
DISCRETION ON MUCH WEIGHTIER
ISSUES. SUCH AS WHETHER TO
IMPOSE THE DEATH PENALTY
WHETHER TO STRIKE TO STRIKE
CONVICTION. WHETHER A CASE
SHOULD PROCEED IN JUVENILE
COURT OR BE TRANSFERRED TO
CRIMINAL COURT WHICH WOULD BE
ADULT COURT. WHEN IT COMES TO
SOMETHING CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
HAVE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH. MANDATORY MINIMUM
SENTENCES ARE NOT AFFECTED IN
ANY WAY INCLUDING NOT BEING
COST EFFECTIVE. ENACTING SENATE
BILL SEVENTY THREE WILL PERMIT
MORE EFFECTIVE DESCENDED BATES
SENTENCING. AND MORE EFFICIENT
USE OF CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL
JUSTICE RESOURCES. I'M URGING A
AYE VOTE IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NOW ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN FAVOR
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES IN A
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM. AND AT&T
OPERATOR CAN OPEN UP LINE FOR
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN THREE SEVENTY THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT THE
SAID THAT TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME AN OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER ARE PLAIN
PLACE YOU BACK IN QUEUE. OUR
FIRST PARTICIPANT WILL BE LINE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MISTER
MEMBERS PAUL YODER HOBBY OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JACKIE ABOUT THEMSELVES
THEY CALIFORNIA ON THE TIME OF
THEM DELEGATE I SUPPORT SB.
SEVEN THREE. FIND FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY DAN
CORRIGAN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
SUPPORT. YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SIX YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
GOING BACK IS FOR DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE SPONSORS IN SUPPORT AS
WELL AS ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS AND NATIONAL HARM
REDUCTION COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SENATOR ON
BEHALF OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA AND MARK
AT THE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NINE NINETY YOU ARE
OPEN. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JIM LINDBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING GREGORY
SET UP WITH INITIATE JUSTICE
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE NINETY SEVEN EUROPE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CAME ACKERMAN IMPLANT
BY VOTERS ON BEHALF OF SPAM IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROME THE
AIRLINE ROSTEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT FROM THE C. W. P. THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED ONE YOU ARE ALL BUT.
GOOD MORNING KUMAR TOOK OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
MORNING LESLIE BASKET ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
AND AGAIN I TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR- SB SEVEN THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND LINE
TWENTY SIX YOU ARE ALL BUT. I
THINK THEY TOOK THEMSELVES OUT
TWENTY SIX IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RE PROMPT PLEASE- PRESS ONE
ZERO AGAIN. TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ANTHONY DIMARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
SIXTY EIGHT. YOU ARE OPEN SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
SIXTEEN ARE YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI YEAH THIS
IS THE LONG GOING TO HAPPEN HL
YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO BACK TO
LIKE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO. LINE
NINETY TWO YOUR OPEN. HI THIS
IS COMFORT JONES MUHAMMAD WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSEMBLY SLAVERY
DEFENDANTS LOS ANGELES AND
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE ONE MORE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WHITE ONE HUNDRED SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JACKIE AND I'M CONTENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA- CAMPAIGNS THE
DELEGATE AND I SUPPORT SB SEVEN
THREE. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
THERE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP THANK YOU I'VE SEEN
NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES GOING
TO THE AUDIENCES MANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION SEEN NONE GOING
TO THE- TELEPROMPTER ROOM AND-
ANY WITNESSES TELL CONFERENCE
ROOM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. EIGHTEEN THE
OPERATOR NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
FOR S. SEVENTY THREE- ARE THERE
ANY ON THE LINE. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR SB SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. CHAU
OPPOSITION FOR SB SEVEN THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTY SIX. FOR SURE REMEMBERS
SKIPPING RAIN TO CARRY OUT
TERRORIST ASSOCIATES WILL BE
HAPPY. CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HYDRO I'M CORRECT IN OPPOSITION.
THANK ADELINE ONE HUNDRED
CORPORATE THANK YOU THANK YOU
WHAT ONE OH FOUR. AT CHAIR
MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE PRIMARILY
BECAUSE THE BILL INCLUDES
CRIMES INVOLVING CHILDREN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS CUED UP
MISTER CHAIR- BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE OR ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE JUST DID- HOW MOVE THE BELL
OKAY CAN YOU ADD ME AS A CO
AUTHOR I WOULD LOVE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU OKAY WELL I
LIKE ALMOST EVERYONE IN YOUR
PATH- SO THE OPPOSITION IS
COMPLAINING THAT PEOPLE WON'T
GET PUNISHED- FIRST OF ALL.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT
PUNISHMENT ACTUALLY CAUSES
THERE TO BE LESS IN THE WAY OF
DRUG- BILL TAKING DRUGS PEOPLE
GETTING DRUG OVERDOSES IN FACT
IT PROBABLY KILLS PEOPLE.
BECAUSE WHEN THEY'RE GETTING
DRUNK OF OVERDOSE IS THERE
SOMEWHERE QUIET OR THEY'RE
SHARING NEEDLES AND GET HIV AT
CETERA- IN FACT PORTUGAL IS
GONE TOO NO PUNISHMENT FOR DRUG
POSSESSION. THEY STILL GO AFTER
TRAFFICKERS BUT THERE'S NO
PUNISHMENT FOR DRUG POSSESSION
AND PEOPLE STILL. GO INTO
REHABILITATION FOR IT SO I
THINK THIS WHOLE EFFORT AT
PUNISHING PEOPLE FOR DRUG
POSSESSION IS WRONG BUT- EVEN
SO I AM VOTING FOR A BILL WHICH
WILL ALLOW THE JUDGE TO THROW
THE BOOK AT SOMEONE IF THEY
WANT TO- AND THE OPPOSITION
LETTERS YOU'RE SAYING- THEY'LL
BE NO PUNISHMENT. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE WILL BE PUNISHMENT- SO
THAT I THINK THAT THAT
OPPOSITION ARGUMENT IS WRONG-
BUT FRANKLY I WISH OF HER
RIGHT. BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SAVING PEOPLE BY
PREVENTING THEM FROM TAKING
DRUGS WHEN IN FACT WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT WHEN THEY TAKE DRUGS
RATHER THAN. BEING REALLY
REHABILITATED THEY OFTEN END U
IN JAIL WITH A MUCH WORSE LIFE
THAN THEY WOULD HAVE HAD IF WE
WEREN'T ENFORCING THESE LAWS.
SO THAT- THAT'S WHY I'M
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I
WOULD SUPPORT JUST
DECRIMINALIZING THAT BEGAN WITH
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ARE CONCERNED. YOU MAY
CLOSE. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN I DO AN EXAM WE'RE A
LITTLE BIT SURPRISED BY- THE-
LATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OPPOSITION- THEY'VE NOT OPPOSE
THIS BILL IN THE PAST THE DA'S
ASSOCIATION ACTUALLY WHEN THIS
BILL WAS INTRODUCED A FEW
MONTHS AGO SCORED IN THE
PROCESS. SENATE THEY HAD NO
ISSUE WITH THAT SO IT'S A
LITTLE BIT SURPRISING- AND I DO
JUST WANT TO MENTION IN TERMS
OF- MINERS EXISTING LAW CREATES
A PRESUMPTION AGAINST
PROBATION- FOR CASES INVOLVING
MINORS- IT FOR RELATING TO
COCAINE METH AND HEROIN. BUT
THEN THERE ARE OTHER DRUGS THAT
IT BANS PROBATION SO WE'RE
SIMPLY ALIGNING IT TO CURRENT
LAW FOR METH COCAINE AND
HEROIN- SO I JUST DON'T THINK
ABOUT IS A PARTICULARLY
COMPELLING ARGUMENT GIVEN THAT
WERE REALLY JUST ALIGNING
UNDER. ALREADY EXISTING LAW
WITH RESPECT TO MYERS A CREATES
A STRONG PRESUMPTION AGAINST
OPERATIONS SO OCT COLORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AND
AGAIN I WANNA THANK YOU ARE THE
IRONIC PART IS A WHEN MR QUIRK
AND I FIRST GOT HERE IN TWENTY
TWELVE WHEN IT WHEN AND WHEN
NOT WE SAT ON THIS COMMITTEE
BACK BACK IN THE DAY A WE DON'T
TRUST JUDGES. CATIONS DIVERSION
PROGRAMS. OBVIOUSLY WE'VE COME
A LONG WAY TO WHERE WE ARE NOW
WANTED TO TRUST JUDGES TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS SAID IT'S JUST
AND I GUESS IN A RELATIVELY
SHORT PERIOD TIME EIGHT YEARS-
THIS DOES BODY IS NOW WILLING
TO ENTRUST- JUDGES DOING THEIR
JOB. AND DOING IT AND NOT A
COMPASSIONATE WAY BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
NEED TO GO TO JAIL. WILL GO TO
JAIL AND SO- IT FOR ME IT'S A-
IT SHOWS HOW THE SYSTEM CAN CAN
CHANGE A MOVE FOR TO BECOME. A
LITTLE MORE COMPASSION IN
PROGRESSIVE BUT MOST IMPORTANT
HOW JUDGES CAN EVEN CHANGE-
BECAUSE WE USED TO FILL THEM
WITH THAT OF FORMER PROSECUTORS
AND- AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
AND SO ON RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
JURORS RECOMMENDED AND I.
CALDERON ON SB SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER IRAQI
NO. LACKEY NEL PARA CAN
BARRICADE HAD I LEE. LEE I WORK
HARD WORK I SANTIAGO. C. A. R.
TELL. WICKS MEASURES ON CALL
MEASURES ON CALL EACH ONE MARK
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. NOT ITEM NUMBER FIVE
CORTES. SB THREE EIGHT THREE I.
WAS A KID CASEY. SENATOR HOW
YOU PRONOUNCE YOUR NAME. CORTEZ
HE FOR CASEY SORRY ABOUT THAT
SENATOR CORTEZ YOU WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY IT'S FIVE THE
PRECIADO IN THE QUESTION AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN
MEMBERS I'M I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB THREE EIGHTY THREE
THE JUVENILE DIVERSION ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SB THREE TWO
THREE SIX TO EXPAND. THE
REHABILITATION OPPORTUNITIES
FOR YOUTH WHO COMMIT NONVIOLENT
FELONIES BY INCREASING ACCESS
TO DIVERSION PROGRAMS. BY DOING
THIS WE CAN ASSURE THAT A
SPECIALIZED SOLUTION IS
PROVIDED FOR YOUTH INSTEAD OF A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH. IN
TWO THOUSAND. THE PASSAGE OF
PROP TWENTY ONE GREATLY LIMITED
ELIGIBILITY FOR JUVENILE
DIVERSION. HOWEVER MODERN THE
RESEARCH ON ADOLESCENT BEHAVIOR
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT CONFIRM. THAT
YOUTHFULNESS MATTERS AND THAT
YOU SHOULD BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY THAN ADULTS. SB
THREE EIGHTY THREE FOLLOWS
RESEARCH BY MAKING YOU CHARGED
WITH FELONIES THAT ARE NOT
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT ELIGIBLE
FOR INFORMAL SUPERVISION.
ADDITIONALLY SB THREE EIGHTY
THREE INSURERS THAT YOUTH
ALLEGED TO HAVE SOLD OR
POSSESSED FOR SALE THE
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE ARE NOT
EXCLUDED FROM RECEIVING
INFORMAL SUPERVISION. SB THREE
EIGHTY THREE ALSO REMOVES
UNNECESSARY PROCEDURAL BARRIERS
TO WILL ALLOW USE COUNTY OF
RESIDENCE CAN TO CONDUCT AN
ANALYSIS. OF THE USE NEEDS
ENOUGH IF APPROPRIATE OFFER
INFORMAL SUPERVISION THROUGH
DIVERSION PROGRAM. FINALLY SB
THREE EIGHTY THREE INSURERS
THAT INDIGENT YOUTHS ARE NOT
DENIED ELIGIBILITY FOR
DIVERSION PROGRAMS DUE TO THEIR
INABILITY TO MAKE RESTITUTION
PAYMENT. MANY OF THESE ALL STEM
FROM A TOUGH ON CRIME PERIOD
WERE THESE YOUTH WERE OFTEN
LABELED AS SUPER PREDATORS. AT
THIS POINT IN TIME WE NOW KNOW
THE HARSH SENTENCES IN
INCREASED PUNISHMENTS
ESPECIALLY FOR YOUTH DOES
LITTLE TO MITIGATE CRIME.
INSTEAD TOUGH ON CRIME LAWS
WITH YOUTH CREATE A CARCERAL
SOCIETY THAT DEHUMANIZES THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OF
CRIMES. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
RIGHT THIS WRONG. HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY OVER THE PHONE-
IS MIKE VOTE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU AGAIN MR THANK YOU
SIR. THANK MR BELOW YOU MAY
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CARE HAS NOTED
I AM MIKE BELOW SPEAKING FOR
THE JUVENILE COURT JUDGES-
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS A SECTION
OF THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION THAT WE REALLY
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
SORT OF A RIGHT. TECH CHANGES
TO THE LAW ON JUVENILE
DIVERSION FIRST THANK YOU FOR
THE EXCELLENT ANALYSIS IT'S A
REALLY CLEAR ARTICULATION OF
THE PRINCIPLES OF THE INFORMAL
SUPERVISION AND DEFERRED ENTRY
OF JUDGMENT- AS NOTED BY CENTER
COURT HAS THE BILL- CLEANS UP
THE PROCESS WHICH OCCURS WHEN A
USER IS ARRESTED IN ONE COUNTY
BUT HE IS- A RESIDENT OF
ANOTHER. ALLOWING THE HOME
COUNTY TO MAKE A SUITABILITY
DETERMINATION- OF DIVERSION
SECONDLY IT REMOVES IMPEDIMENTS
FOR FIRST TIME SIRIK NON
SERIOUS NONVIOLENT FELONIES.
FOR A DIVERSION TO BE ORDERED
WE JUST THINK THAT THERE ARE
OCCASIONS WHERE A JUDGE-
PURSUANT TO THAT KIND OF
DISCRETION THAT THE KERR
MENTIONED IN THE LAST BILL.
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A
DIVERSION ORDER- SO WE THINK
IT'S A RIGHT ATCH WE
APPRECIATE CENTER CORTEZ THE WE
APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS AND WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU SIR ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT INDIE FORTY TWO OH
TWO SEEN NONE THEY WITNESSES IN
THE VIDEO TELECONFERENCING ROOM
SCENE NINE AND EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR YOU MAY NOT OPEN UP
THE LINES. FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. I OF A- OF BILL. THANK
YOU FIVE TWO SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. WE WILL BEGIN WITH
LINE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT HASN'T GONE BACK
THE PROSECUTORS LINE CALIFORNIA
IF THE COURT. WHY ONE HUNDRED
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. BY NINETEEN YOU ARE
OPEN. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. NINE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AT. YOU ON YOUR ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN SUPPORT. FIND ONE
HUNDRED TEN YOU ARE OPEN.
COMARCA CUT ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND SUPPORT.
BY NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TO ME TO SEE WHAT NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER SHOWING
SUPPORT THANK YOU. A LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE ONE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND BEGIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR-
SB THREE THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP THANK
YOU INSANE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION LAUGHTER ROOM TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION. SIGNON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE- MONITOR C.
NINE. AND AGAIN EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR WE'RE OPEN UP LINES
FOR ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SB THREE EIGHT THREE. THANK YOU
MISS ERRIGAN CHAU OPPOSITION
FOR SB THREE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BYZERO ONE FILED
BY ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION.
NOBODY IS GOING UP AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. CNN YOU MAY SENATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IT
RECOMMENDING I'D MET SECRETARY
MAY CALL THE ROLL ON SB THREE
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR CORTESE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY NO BARRICADE CAN
BARRICADE I BELIEVE LEE I WORK
AYE CORK AYE SANTIAGO. C. A. R.
TELL WICKS. MEASURES ARE CALLED
WE NEED ONE MORE OKAY THANK YOU
GET THANK YOU. NOW WE HAVE
SENATOR DODD. S. B. FOUR NINE
FOUR. THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING THE BILL THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FIRST I
WANT TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
FOR THE COMMITTEE'S EFFORTS ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AND THE
AND ALICE'S. THIS LEGISLATURE
THIS COMMITTEE IS ALL TOO
FAMILIAR WITH LEGISLATION IN
RECENT YEARS TO TRY TO REFORM
AND IMPROVE POLICING IN
CALIFORNIA SB FOUR NINETY FOUR
IS A SMALL BUT IMPORTANT STEP
TO ADDRESS HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS TRAINED TO INTERACT WITH THE
PUBLIC FROM A VERY FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING. BE IN THE
POLICE ACADEMY OR THE ROBERT
PRESSLEY INSTITUTE OF CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION. OVER THE PAST
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS POLICE HAVE
RELIED ON CRIMINAL
INTERROGATION STRATEGY KNOWN AS
THE REID TECHNIQUE. WHICH
RELIES HEAVILY ON ASSUMING
GUILT ASSESSING BEHAVIORAL
CLUES OF DECEPTION IN
ADMINISTERING PSYCHOLOGICAL
MANIPULATION. QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN RAISED ABOUT THE VALIDITY
OF THE TECHNIQUE WITH STUDIES
SHOWING THE ABILITY OF THE
OFFICE- TO DETECT DECEPTION
AROUND 54% IT'S KIND OF THE
SAME IS- FLIPPING A COIN- SB
FOUR NINETY FOUR WILL HELP
ENSURE OFFICERS ARE PROPERLY
TRAINED IN THE PUBLIC SN'T
SUBJECTED TO DEMEANING OR
COURTSOF TACTICS THAT CAN
RESULT IN FALSE CONFECTIONS SB
FOUR NINETY FOUR WOULD REQUIRE
OPPOSED TO CREATE IT IN A GREAT
OFFICER TRAINING ON INTERVIEW
TECHNIQUES THAT ARE MORE
ETHICAL AND EFFECTIVE IT
GETTING ACCURATE INFORMATION
WHILE AVOIDING. FALSE
CONFESSIONS. WE ARE CONTINUE
WORK WITH POST TO ENSURE
REQUIREMENTS THE BILL ARE
WORKABLE THE BILL SUPPORTED BY
THE MULTIPLE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICES AS WELL AS
IN THE SAID PROJECT- TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF FOUR NINETY FOUR
TODAY'S BURN PEARSON EL DORADO
COUNTY. DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
THANK YOU AND YOUR WITNESS MAY
BEGIN- BURN PEARSON WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR A COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND SENATOR DODD- IT
INDICATED MY NAME IS BURNED
PEARSON I AM THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY DOLLAR OUT OF COUNTY
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING SENATOR- DIAPERS FOR
HIS WORK ON THIS AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR- WORK
IN TERMS OF OFFERING THE
VARIOUS- CLARIFYING AMENDMENT-
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FIRST
FOR PERMITTING SPEAK UP ON THIS
AND VERY IMPORTANT- STAFF.
TODAY IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT- SOME
OF THOSE PROGRESS TO BE EIGHT
AND MOST CONSERVATIVE DH COME
TOGETHER BUT THEY HAVE ON THIS
BILL IT'S ALSO NOT OFTEN THAT
THAT GUY IS YOU KNOW THAT THE
INNOCENCE PROJECT MODEL LINE-
WITH THE VARIOUS DJS ON
SOMETHING OF THIS NATURE BUT
RESEARCHERS SHOWN THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS CAN BETTER
SERVE THE COMMUNITY WHEN
THEY'RE TRAINED ON SCIENCE
BASED ETHICAL HUMAN
INTERVIEWING ENGAGEMENT
STRATEGIES I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY
MENTION TO YOU WHY I PERSONALLY
AM SO COMMITTED THAT THE THIRTY
YEAR PROSECUTOR TO SEE THIS
THIS BILL- CHECK. PASSED AND- A
CHANGE TO THE WAY WE TRAINED
LAW ENFORCEMENT HERE IN THE
STATE. OF CALIFORNIA- THE
PROJECT PRO ME SOME YEARS AGO.
AND REQUESTED A REVIEW OF
INTERVIEW IN THE MURDER
CONVICTION. MANY YEARS EARLIER
AND AYE SIR DO ATTORNEY GENERAL
WOULDN'T BOTHER BY THE
INTERVIEW. OF THE SUSPECT'S
GIRLFRIEND WHO ULTIMATELY
CONFESSED TO PARTICIPATING IN
THE BRUTAL MURDER OF A WOMAN IN
IMPLICATED HER BOYFRIEND RICKY
DAVIS. BUT TO BE HONEST I WAS
SKEPTICAL OF THE CLAIM THAT HE
WAS FACTUALLY INNOCENT. BUT I
WAS WILLING TO BUCK I BOTHERED
BY IT SUFFICIENTLY TO INITIATE-
CONTINUED TESTING OF FORENSIC
EVIDENCE- AND YEAH WE DID
EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF TESTING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY- CRIME LAB. OVER TIME
OUR INVESTIGATORS AND
ULTIMATELY USING GENETIC
GENEALOGY WERE ABLE TO
EXONERATE RICKY DAVIS. BUT
NOTHING TO DO WITH WRECKAGE
WRONGFUL CONVICTION AND
INCARCERATION I FELT DUTY BOUND
TO MEET WITH HIM IN CUSTODY IN
PERSON AND APOLOGIZE. TO HIM
FOR THE WRONGFUL CONVICTION AND
TO SECURE IT HAS RELEASED. I
ALSO MADE A COMMITMENT TO
CHANGE THE WAY OUR OFFICERS ARE
TRAINED. IN THE WAKE OF
ENHANCED ENHANCED INTERROGATION
REVELATIONS NO BOMB
ADMINISTRATION COMMISSION A
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTIGATION
INTO INTELLIGENCE POLICE
PRACTICES. THE RESEARCHERS WILL
BE OAK MUCH OF WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN TRAINING OFFICERS OF THE
LAST SEVEN YEARS IT'S
INEFFECTIVE AND LONG. IN OTHER
WORDS RESEARCH INCLUDING MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED SEPARATE PEER
REVIEWED STUDIES REVEALED
AGGRESSIVE CONFESSION DRIVEN
INTERROGATIONS ARE MISGUIDED
AND INCREASE THE RISK OF FALSE.
INFORMATION INCLUDING FALSE
CONFESSIONS- ETHICAL REPORT
BASED APPROACH IS GROUNDED IN
FACT FINDING ORTRUTH SEEKING
BETTER PROTECT. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. RESEARCH REVEALS
ALL POLICING CAN BENEFIT BY AND
ONE PERSON PROFICIENT. IN THAT
HUMAN ENGAGE AND- COMMUNICATION
SKILLS THIS AFTER HUMAN
TRAINING SHOULD BE INCORPORATED
WITHIN WITHIN THE LEARNING
DOMAINS FROM THE ACADEMY AND
THROUGHOUT AN OFFICER'S CAREER.
SB FOUR NINETY FOUR REQUIRES
POSTED BY JANUARY. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TO ESSENTIALLY
CONVENE A MEETING AT A PANEL OF
EXPERTS- BOTH FROM A TRAINING
PERSPECTIVE BOB RESEARCH
PERSPECTIVE- AT PROSECUTORS TO
CONVENE TOGETHER IN THE NEXT
ANALYZE THE TRAINING CURRICULUM
THAT IS CURRENTLY PER PRESENTED
BOTH AT THE ACADEMY LEVEL. AND
IF THE- DICEY I COURSE THE
DETECTIVE COURSE- AND TO
INCORPORATE SCIENCE BASED
ETHICAL HUMAN ENGAGEMENT WITHIN
THOSE VARIOUS LEARNING DOMAINS.
I'M ABOUT TO BE CLEAR THE BILL
WOULD NOT REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
COURSES TO BE ADDED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACADEMY. THAT IT
WOULD REQUIRE POST TO-
INCORPORATE THESE STRATEGIES
WITHIN THE FORTY THREE EXISTING
LEARNING DOMAINS I PERSONALLY
HAVE ATTENDED- THIS TYPE OF
TRAINING BOTH WITH THE NYPD
THAT THE AS WELL AS WITH THE
LAPD. HI AND- MY INVESTIGATORS
NOW BROADER COUNTIES WELL AS
THOSE FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
IN YOLO COUNTY AND ATTENDED
THIS TYPE OF TRAINING I WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE HER AYE VOTE
AND. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU WE NOW BRING IT INTO THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT. ANYONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- TO I WOULD GO TO
TELECOM SCREEN ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. AT&T OPERATOR WILL NOT
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR SUPPORT
FOR S. B. FOUR NINE FOUR. AS MR
CARE SAID THAT TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR SB FOUR NINETY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR NINETY FOUR.
NO ONE MOMENT WE'RE GETTING A
COUPLE QUEUEING UP FOR AT LEAST
ONE. FOR ANYBODY ALKALOID HIT.
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR NINE FOUR
AND WE WILL GO. TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING HEARING
MEMBERS ADDISON MICHELLE THOMAS
SHARP REPRESENTING THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. I'M SURE WE HAVE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP THANK
YOU AND SEEING NO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL ALLOW THE SAME
FOR ANY OPPOSITION IN FORTY TWO
OH TWO. SEEING NONE WILL GO TO
THE TELECONFERENCING SCREEN-
SEEN NONE AT&T OPERATOR DO THE
SAME FOR OPPOSITION FOR S. B.
FOUR NINE FOUR YOU CAN NOW OPEN
UP THE LINES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE SHOP PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB FOUR
NINE FOUR. PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE'RE GETTING
NOBODY QUEUEING UP AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
MISSED DIRTY LACKEY. YEAH FIRST
OF ALL I'D LIKE TO- KIND OF
CORRECT THE RECORD THE CASE
THERE'S ANY MISUNDERSTANDING.
THERE'S VERY LITTLE INSTRUCTION
AT THE ACADEMY LEVEL. ON
CONDUCTING INTERVIEW AND
INTERROGATION. TECHNIQUES MOST
OF THIS KIND OF- INSTRUCTION
THERE'S FOR ADVANCED. INTERVIEW
AND INTERROGATION CIRCUMSTANCE
LIKE DETECTIVE OR ARE BEYOND
THAT AND- I DO AGREE THAT-
THERE'S BEEN SOME SUSPECT
CIRCUMSTANCES RESULTING FROM
THE STRAINING THERE THERE NEEDS
TO BE ADJUSTMENTS MADE BUT I DO
HAVE CONCERNS I AM GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. FOR JUST
BECAUSE OF- I THINK SOMETHING
NEEDS TO BE DONE. BUT I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT. THIS QUOTE
UNQUOTE ADVANCED IN PERSONAL.
COMMUNICATION SKILLS ARE
EXACTLY WHAT THAT MEANS. NOT
SURE WHAT THAT MEANS. AND I'VE
CONDUCTED MORE THAN MY SHARE OF
INTERVIEW AND INTERROGATIONS.
I'M JUST A LITTLE BIT WORRIED
AS LONG AS WE'RE GETTING TO THE
TRUTH I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE
THE FOCUS. NOT THE- THE
POLITICAL HANDLING OF THE WAY
THAT- SO WE GET TO THE TRUTH I
THINK THAT THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THE PUBLIC DESERVES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR-
YES OUR K. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR YOU KNOW IN MY TIME
DEFENDING INDIVIDUALS- THEY
WERE ALLEGED COMMITTED CRIMES I
SAW MY FAIR SHARE OF STATEMENTS
TAKEN THAT DIDN'T SEEM WHOLLY
TRUTHFUL SOME COURTS DEEMED
UNTRUTHFUL AND I THINK THAT TO
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE MR LACKEY
SAID WHAT WE WANT MOST IS THE
TRUTH AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THIS
BILL IS GIVE THOSE MEN AND
WOMEN ON THE FRONT LINES WHO
ARE OUT THERE TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND TO ENSURE THAT
ONLY THOSE WHO ARE GUILTY OR
TRULY CHARGED AND CONVICTED FOR
CRIMES THE TOOLS TO DO JUST
THAT AND YOU KNOW I THINK THIS
I AM NOT AN EXPERT IN WHAT THAT
TECHNIQUE IS AND I HOPE THAT
THIS REALLY IS GETTING OUT THE
BEST WAY BUT I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT TOO MANY PEOPLE ARE
SERVING TIME FOR CRIMES THEY
DIDN'T COMMIT BECAUSE 1% IS TOO
MANY AND SO I THINK YOU FOR
THIS WORK AND- I'M- WITH FORTY
SPORTING. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. YOU
MAY CLOSE MISSED CENTER DOT
OUTFIT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE ALL THE
COMMENTS THERE HERE THIS
MORNINGYOU KNOW THIS BILL AS I
KIND OF MENTIONED THAT A
DIFFERENT WAY BUT IT'S NO
SILVER BULLET ALL BY ITSELF.
IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE
WORLD BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS
LOOKING AT THIS BILL WHETHER OR
NOT I WAS GOING TO TAKE THIS
BILL ON IT WORK THIS BILL THIS
YEAR I JUST THOUGHT THIS IS
JUST ONE OF THE KEY ELEMENTS.
IN A LOT OF THE AREAS THAT ARE
BEING WORKED ON IN OUR
LEGISLATURE- THIS YEAR AND
SOME- LAST YEAR I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU A
CHURCH RECOMMEND THE I AND I
WOULD. TAKE UP MISTER LACKEYS-
SUGGESTING THAT YOU CLARIFY
BECAUSE IT'S- IF YOU SET THE
TWO OF US TOGETHER. I HAVE A
VERY CLEAR UNDERSTANDING. WHO
ARE YOU GETTING THAT AND- IT
NOT SO MUCH. AND SO- AND PLUS
OTHER **** HE SAID. I WANT
THREE DECADES PLEASE ALLOW
YEARS OF TRAINING I KNOW A LOT
OF. IT UP RESEARCHERS SILVA. AS
YOU BUT A I THINK HIS HIS
ADVICE WOULD BE VERY VALUABLE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I KEEP THE
CHURCH RECOMMENDED I. SB FOUR
NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR DODD THE
MISSION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER ATTY LACKEY. LACKEY I
OUR CAN BARRICADE HAND I LEAD
LEE BY COURT. MARK I SAN DIEGO.
CA ARE TO WICKS WICKS I. THAT
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PROCEEDED
THANK YOU. AND- FOR A LAST I
REMEMBER EIGHT SENATOR ROTH SB.
SIX TO NINE AND THAT WOULD BE
IDENTIFICATION CARDS. THANK YOU
REST THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
AS YOU KNOW THIS BILL EXPANDS
THE PATHWAYS FOR INMATES TO
TAKE PART IN CDC OURS CAL ID
PROGRAM- NEARLY EVERY
INDIVIDUAL RELEASED FROM STATE
PRISON FACES SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
AND THE LACK OF A VALID
CALIFORNIA ID OR DRIVER'S
LICENSE FOR THAT MATTER CAN
EXCESS EXACERBATE THESE
BARRIERS SEEKING MEDICAL CARE
RECEIVING HOUSING ASSISTANCE.
APPLYING FOR JOBS OPENING A
BANK ACCOUNT WITHOUT A VALID ID
NEARLY ALL OF THESE AND
CERTAINLY NEWLY RELEASED
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE LOCKED OUT
OF CRUCIAL SERVICES AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO SUCCEED. CDCR
CURLY PROVIDES A PATHWAY FOR
INMATES TO OBTAIN OUT KELLY
DISEASES THEY APPROACH THEIR
RELEASE BUT A REQUIREMENT IN
THE STATUTE HAS PRECLUDED
THOUSANDS OF THOSE WHO WERE
OTHERWISE READY AN ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE KELLY D.
PROGRAM FROM DOING SO. UNDER
THE CURRENT STATUTE AGAIN AS
YOU KNOW I'M SURE ELIGIBLE
INMATES MUST HAVE AMONG OTHER
REQUIREMENTS A USABLE PHOTO ON
FILE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES IT IS NO MORE
THAN TEN YEARS OLD THIS IS
PROVEN TO BE DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THOSE INMATES
RELEASED SOME OF THEM TO MEET
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ELDERLY WHO HAVE SERVED LEAGUE
THE LENGTHY SENTENCES OR WHO
DID NOT POSSESS A CAL ID PRIOR
TO SERVING THEIR SENTENCE. THE
BILL ADDRESSES THIS BY AMENDING
THE CURRENT PHOTO REQUIREMENT
FOR CAL ID RENEWAL. TO ALLOW US
ARE TO TAKE A NEW PHOTO FOR
INMATES WHOSE DMV PHOTO WAS
DEEMED UNUSABLE. IT ALSO
EXTENDS A NEW PHOTO OPPORTUNITY
TO THOSE WHO DID NOT POSSESS
THE KELADI PRIOR TO THEIR
INCARCERATION. AND EXTENDS THE
EXISTING REDUCED FEE. OF EIGHT
DOLLARS TO APPLY TO FIRST TIME
ID APPLICANTS. MELT STRUCTURE
YOU IN THE COMMITTEE SET US
SOME PROPOSED AMENDMENTS-
DESIGNED TO MORE CLOSELY ALIGN
THIS BILL WITH THE BILL
CURRENTLY CARRIED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE AB. SEVEN
SEVENTEEN- I HAVE REVIEWED THE
THOSE AMENDMENTS. I YOU KNOW I
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE MEMBER STONE HAS BEEN
A CHAMPION OF THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE OR THESE ISSUES FOR
SEVERAL SEVERAL YEARS. AND I
WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT I AM
COMPLETELY SUPPORTIVE OF
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVENTEEN
AND THE GENERAL CONCEPTS
CONTAINED- IN THAT BILL AND
THEN THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
THAT YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF SAID TO ME. THERE ARE
SOME POTENTIAL COST ISSUES WITH
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS OF AB
SEVEN SEVENTEEN. AND FRANKLY
PRIOR TO INTRODUCING THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. MY STAFF
CONSULTED WITH MR STONE'S
OFFICE ON HIS BILL AND THE
PROPOSED BILL THAT WE INTENDED
TO INTRODUCE. IF IT WORKED OUT-
AND IN DOING SO WE DECIDED TO
INTRODUCE THE BILL TO PROVIDE
FRANKLY. A COST NEUTRAL
ALTERNATIVE. AND TO SERVE AS A
BACK UP TO HIS BILL IF FUNDING
WAS NOT DEEMED APPROPRIATE OR
COULD NOT BE SECURED. I HAVE
SPOKEN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
ON RECONCILING THE PROVISIONS
OF AB SEVEN SEVENTEEN AND THIS
BILL. AND I AM ABSOLUTELY
WILLING TO WORK WITH HIM AS I
TOLD HIM. ALONG WITH CDCR AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BOTH OF
WHOM ARE INVOLVED IN THIS
ISSUE. TO TRY TO PUT THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE COMPONENT BACK
INTO THIS BILL THIS SENATE
BILL. TO ELIMINATE THE FINES
AND FEES ISSUE. THAT THIS BILL
CURRENTLY HAS AND TO FIGURE
SOME WAY TO PROVIDE DOCUMENT
ASSISTANCE TO INDIVIDUAL
SERVING- IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM
RECOGNIZING THAT CDCR FRANKLY
AT THIS POINT IS NOT PRESENTLY
EQUIPPED. TO SERVICE A DOCUMENT
RETRIEVAL SERVICE. SO WITH THAT
I'M COMMITTED CERTAINLY TO DO
THAT IF IT IS THE DESERVE YOU
AND THIS COMMITTEE TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD TO X. NEXT STOP-
IN THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE MISTER
KEVIN HOFFMAN WHO WAS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF PROGRAM
OPERATIONS AT CDC OURS DIVISION
OF REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
SIMPLY TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT YOU OR THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE- AND WITH THAT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IF YOU DEEM THAT
APPROPRIATE. OKAY DID MR CAUGHT
HOFFMAN ONE MAKE A STATEMENT
FOR PURPOSES OF DISCUSSION NOW
MOVES THE BILL. I MAKING THE
MISTER OFTEN AVAILABLE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS OR NK
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU PREFER A
STATEMENT HE'S NOT. HE DOESN'T
HAVE TO- SO WE- ARE THERE ANY.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN A ROW.
FOR THE BILL ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON A TELECONFERENCING.
AT EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR OR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. FOR SB
SIX TO NINE. THANK YOU
MEDICARE- TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB SIX TO NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER AND THEN PLACE YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE A LINE ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BIRTH PRESS OR
GET OFF ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. BY
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BURKE
GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE
EIGHTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES MORROW YOU
MAY BEGIN YOUR HEARING DAVID
ORGANIZATION MARC ALMOND ALMOND
OKAY ALMORAVIDS THIRTY ALLEN
ROBINSON CALIFORNIA LAWYERS FOR
THE ARTS IN SUPPORT OF SB. SIX
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CARING
COMMITTEE MEMBER IF YOU WANT TO
OR ON BEHALF EIGHT BILLION
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FIND TWENTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN. DANIEL GOOD CARILLO
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. NINE FORTY SIX.
PLEASE GO AHEAD FORTY SIX.
FORTY SIX ARE YOU WORK ON
BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX TO NINE THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ELVISH DURING AN ONLINE SUPPORT
YOU COULD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALSO MIGHT WANT. HELLO YES YOUR
OPEN CERTAIN. HELLO THIS IS
TOWARD MORE AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY.
GOOD TO KNOW THANK YOU. SENATE.
HI THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU I CEDAR NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO
WE'LL GO TO THE FORTY TWO OH
TWO RD WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE TO TELECONFERENCING
C. NONE. TO THE- TELESCOPIC
CONFERENCE PHONE LINES. I KNEW
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOUR SB SIX TO
NINE. INITIAL YEAR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO AND WE ARE GETTING NOBODY
QUEUEING UP AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MISTER CORK. SO
I'VE FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING WILLING TO
TAKE THOSE CHANGES TO THE BILL-
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT COST
THAT COULD BE AN ISSUE I THINK
IT IS WOULD PROBABLY BE A GOOD
IDEA. TO HAVE YOUR BILL AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO SEVEN ONE SEVEN
SHOULD THE GOVERNOR TO SIGN
THAT. CDC ARE IS NOT CAPABLE OR
DOESN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
DO THIS- THAT ALSO SEEMS TO BE
WE'RE HEARING MANY OF THE SAME
GROUPS WHO SUPPORTED SEVEN ONE
SEVEN SUPPORTING YOUR BAIL. SO
AT THE MOMENT AND I AM
PREDISPOSED TO VOTING FOR IT I
DO WANT TO HEAR WHAT THE- WHAT
ARE CHAIR HAS TO SAY ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW HIS
POSITION YET. THANK YOU. MR
LACKEY YEAH I- IN ITS CURRENT
FORM I'M CLEARLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE- BUT YOU MIGHT BE
TALKING ME OUT OF IT-
EVENTUALLY EMERGING IT WAS
SEVEN SEVENTEEN AND HERE'S
HERE'S MY BIGGEST CONCERN OVER
SEVEN SEVENTEEN. THE DRIVER'S
LICENSE ISSUE- DOES NOT ADDRESS
ANY KIND OF BEHIND THE WHEEL
TRAINING AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S A PUBLIC SAFETY VOID
DEBTS- VERY COULD- VERY
IMPORTANT. AND- SO HAVING A
FORM OF A GOOD IDENTIFICATION
IS CLEARLY SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED BUT NOT IN THE
FORM OF A DRIVER'S LICENSE
UNLESS THERE'S- A CERTAIN
DEGREE OF COMPETENCY THAT'S
DEMONSTRATED BEFORE ISSUING-
THE DRIVING COMPONENT IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MORE
CRITICAL ASPECTS. OF THE- THE
ASSESSMENT PROCESS BEFORE
GETTING A DRIVER'S LICENSE AND-
IT WOULD CLEARLY JUST BE
DISMISSED OR OVERLOOKED. AND I
FIND THAT TO BE UNACCEPTABLE
BUT IN THIS CURRENT FORM I'M
CLEARLY IN SUPPORT AND I THINK
IT IT ADDRESSES A VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEM THANK YOU. ANYWHERE I
MAY RESPOND SURE. WELL SIR I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU I WAS
NOT IN THE- CONSTRUCTION FOR
PHASE OF ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SEVENTEEN WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE COPONENT
WOULD HAVE TO BE A RENEWAL
COMPONENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
PREVIOUSLY. I HAVE. HAD A
DRIVER CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S
LICENSE AND SIMPLY HAD HAVE LET
IT EXPIRE AND NEEDED TO BE
RENEWED IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
BUT I CERTAINLY DEFER TO YOU
AND YOUR DECADES OF EXPERIENCE
THAT. HAVING HAD A CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S LICENSE ONCE IT'S
EXPIRED. YOU MAY RENEW IT YOU
MAY HAVE TO TAKE A WRITTEN TEST
BUT YOU'RE NOT REQUIRED. TO
TAKEN ON THE ROAD TEST AGAIN
AND IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN WE
SHOULD PROBABLY SHOULDN'T
TREAT- INMATES EXITING OUR
CORRECTIONS SYSTEM ANY
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE TREAT ANY
OTHER. RESIDENTS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT WOULD
CERTAINLY BE MY INTENT SO
HOPEFULLY. HOPEFULLY I KEEP YOU
IN THE EYE COLUMN. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. YOU MAY
CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE- MISTER MEMBERS
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING EVERYTHING AND I
KNOW PASSED THE BALANCED- WITH
BUDGET CONCERNS AND END UP WHAT
I REALLY WANTED WAS A
DISCUSSION WHICH YOU'RE WILLING
TO HAVE WITH THE ALL PARTIES
CONCERNED- WITHOUT DISASSEMBLY
SILENCE OF THE THINGS WE WANT
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
THAT IN OUR I'LL JUST THROW IN
THERE AND- WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
TRIED TRYING TO MOVE THIS BALL
LAW. YOU DON'T KNOW THAT WE'VE
BEEN THOSE OF US HAVE BEEN HERE
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE WOMEN
TRYING TO GET THIS DONE. FOR A
LONG TIME. IN BETWEEN CDC ARE.
DMB HAVE BEEN THE MOST
FRUSTRATING. ROOP TO TRY TO GET
THIS DONE AND SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET AS MUCH DONE AS
PHYSICALLY POSSIBLE EVEN NOW
SITTING IN HERE JUST HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION OF MAY ADD MORE
COSTS BUT EVEN JUST A
DISCUSSION ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO DRIVE.
IMMIGRANTS INCARCERATED SO LONG
AS YOU ARE YOU STARTED WHEN YOU
WERE SO YOUNG YOU MAY NOT KNOW
HOW TO DRIVE AND SO I'M NOT
TRYING TO ADD MORE COST TO IT
BUT THAT HE BE A THAT IS. A
VALID CONCERN THAT WE MAY HAVE
TO LOOK AT IN THE BILL SO I
HOPE WE CAN GET WE CAN KEEP
MOVE THE BALLDOWN THE ROAD WE
GET SOMETHING A LITTLE MORE-
AND- IT AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
HOPEFULLY OAST THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH ALL PARTIES
CONCERNED. BECAUSE WE ALL WANT
TO HAVE PEOPLE COME OUT AND BE
ABLE TO GET A DRIVER'S LICENSE
HAVE AN ID BE ABLE TO GET A JOB
WHERE THEY MAY HAVE TO DRIVE
AND TO BE OF CITIZENS THAT
HAVE. DIPPED RIDLEY CALL
RETURNING CITIZENS THAT THEY
REALLY FEEL LIKE TO RETURNING
CITIZENS TO SOCIETY I DO YOU
HAVE THAT INTENT MR STONE HAS
THE SAME INTENT AND EVEN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS THE SAME
OBJECTIVE AND SO THAT'S WHY SHE
JUST NEEDED TO GET EVERYBODY.
IN A ROOM AND SEE WHAT. YOU CAN
AND CAN'T WORK AFTER SOME
THINGS. EVEN NOW WITH THE BY
PART IS YOU KNOW WHERE. WE WERE
STRUGGLING. WITH THAT IN THE
BIG PICTURE THE TEN THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT PITCHER. I JUST
THINK DIGITAL SMALL PIECE BUT
THAT'S THE SENIOR HERE THERE
AND IF YOU NEED. THIS COMMITTEE
OR ANYONE OF US TO HELP. MOVE
THIS ALONG- THE JUDGE
RECOMMENDED ICE ROUTE IF YOU
CAN HELP US MOVE THIS ALONG- WE
WILL BE MORE THAN WILLING TO
HELP COULD THIS IS THAT
IMPORTANT TO US. AGAIN I WANT
THANK YOU FOR. HELPING TO MOVE
THIS BALL LOCK THANK YOU MISTER.
THE COLOR OF. SB SIX TWENTY
NINE BY SENATOR ROB THE MISSION
IS TO PASS TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY LACKEY I PARA QUE HAN
PARA QUE HAN HI LEE. LI HI
CORK. CORK HI SANTIAGO SAN
DIEGO I SEE R. TWO. CLICKS
WICKS I MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WILL DO ANY ADD ONS FOR
BOTH CHANGES MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE GO THROUGH ALL THE
MEASURES TAKEN UP TODAY
INCLUDING ANY MEASURES ON CALL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BAUER-KAHAN BARRICADE HAD HI
WICKS WICKS I DON'T NUMBER ONE
HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH A CA
THREE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
SEVENTY ONE BARRICADE HAN
BARRICADE HAD ICE SANTIAGO. SAN
DIEGO I. ITEM NUMBER THREE THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL SB SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR WIENER
SANTIAGO. SAN DIEGO I WICKS
WICKS HI THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
THREE EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR
CORTESE THIS MEASURE WITH ON
CALL SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I WICKS
WICKS HI THAT MEASURE PASSES. I
DON'T NUMBER SIX WITH ONE
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S.
B. FOUR NINETY FOUR BY SENATOR
DODD SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I THE
NUMBER EIGHT SIX S. B. SIXTEEN
AND WAS JUST DISPENSED WITH.
THESE INCLUDE THIS INCLUDES THE
BUSINESS FOR THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.